des oeillets caterina berezovski à nos
collègues de l'arizona et natalia
travail avec les loups et les vols dans
les centres de la réception et de
traitement des messages l'année dernière
nous avons eu deux projets en un seul
une grande conférence de presse et la
ligne directe
aujourd'hui le format de notre mission a
changé l'essentiel c'est cette
conversation en direct entre le
président et les citoyens sans
intermédiaire pendant notre direct vous
allé plusieurs fois entendre parler
d'une application mobile
jean c'est une manière d'accéder dans
notre direct
chaque personne peut y accéder en direct
le président de la russie vladimir
poutine
bonjour
nous sommes dans le centre du traitement
des messages
ici c'est le cintre palpitant du de la
ligne directe derrière nous les
rédacteurs sont en train de traiter les
appels
je vous montre les numéros auxquels vous
pouvez appeler et envoyer des messages
il y a qu un seul moyen d'adresser le
président directement vous pouvez le
faire via un programme spécial moscou
pour poutine est probablement c'est à
vous que le président va répondre dans
notre centre du traitement des messages
le travail est très intense presque 2
millions des réponses ont déjà été
envoyées jusque là le moyen le plus
populaire reste toujours les tabelles
appel à par téléphone mais beaucoup de
personnes déjà apprécié l'application
plus de soucis 150 fois on était un télé
chargé ses applications nos volontaires
s'occupent des ces questions depuis deux
semaines beaucoup de problèmes ont été
réglés avant la demi heure les immigrés
mitch a je peux vous dire cela on en
pratique que dans le direct aux 70 80
questions peuvent être répondre mais
quel est le destin des autres
réponse oui je voudrais commencer par
dire quelques mots à ce sujet qu'est ce
que je veux dire en 2019
quand cette ligne directe à un lieu en
plein format nous avons eu plus de 20
millions de questions et l'année
dernière quand nous avons tenu la
conférence de presser la ligne directe
en même temps il ya eu plusieurs
centaines de milliers de questions mais
je veux dire que on va essayer de faire
en sorte que pas une seule question ne
reste sans réponse
en 2019 comédie
nous avons reçu plus d'un million de
questions le de 500 mille questions ont
été traitées et où tu eu leur réponse
des réponses concrètes
nous continuons notre travail pour
réagir de façon adéquate
il faut amender le cadre normatif
il faut inclure la solution des ces
questions dans les budgets régionaux et
le budget fédéral c'est un travail
énorme
ce travail n'est pas possible sans le
soutien du front fédéral qui participent
à ce travail de façon active à avec les
administrations régionales les
administrations locales fédérales ils
travaillent ensemble pour aider les gens
oui c'est aussi le grand soutien à mme à
moi même parce que laisser les questions
sont adressés à moi mais je m'adresse
tout d'abord aux volontaires à aux gens
qui sont bénévoles qui travaillent avec
ces questions et je voudrais les
remercier de la part des citoyens parce
que ces questions sont adressés à moi
mais vous aider les simples gens et je
vous dis un grand merci et j'espère que
on va procéder de même façon cette année
après cette ligne directe mais j'espère
qu'on va répondre au maximum de
questions même en ligne les gens parlent
des problèmes qui les préoccupent et on
va essayer de résoudre certains
problèmes
je vous rappelle spécial de notre
émission avec la traduction la nouvelle
vague qui enquêtent
souchez les gens veulent savoir qui
seront les règles exactes
pourquoi on disait avant que la
vaccination était volontaire alors que
maintenant deux tiers de personnes qui
travaillent dans des services concrets
sont obligés de se vacciner pourquoi des
événements de masse sont interdits mais
on peut tenir la coupe de l'europe
comment faire en sorte que les
gouverneurs les fonctionnaires et les
citoyens ordinaires comprennent où sont
les règles fixées les jours c'est très
simple mais concernant la coupe de
football 2020 bien sûr avant tout nous
étions obligés de remplir les
engagements de notre état qui est
organisateur qu'aux utilisateurs de
l'hérault 2020 mais c'est très simple en
général il faut comprendre qu'est ce qui
se passe dans ce domaine il faut voir la
loi à l'époque je disais que la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire et je
continue de le dire il faut lire la loi
de 2001 98 1998 pardon il y a deux
composantes
il y a le volet fédéral le calendrier
fédéral de vaccination qui est
obligatoire c'est la vaccination
obligatoire
il ya eu des propositions de d'inclure
la vaccination anti qu'ovide dans ce
calendrier obligatoire la vaccination
fédéral national
mais les députés n'ont pas soutenu cette
proposition et cela dit ce calendrier
fédéral n'exclut pas la vaccination anti
coded est donc
ce n'est pas obligatoire au niveau
fédéral en même temps le deuxième volet
de cette loi nous dit qu'en cas de la
montée de contamination l'épidémie dans
certaines régions de la fédération de
russie sur recommandation des médecins
les gouverneurs des régions ont le droit
de déclarer la fonctionnalité
obligatoire pour certaines catégories de
citoyens et c'est la norme de loi qui le
dit alors les administrations locales
ont saisi cette chance pour rendre cette
vaccination obligatoire ça se fait dans
le cadre de cette loi de 1998 il n'ya
pas donc de contradictions on travaille
dans le cadre de la loi ça c'est une
autre question les décisions des
administrations des dix régions
justement cette fonction d'éviter le
confinement puisque le confinement c'est
ce sont les gens qui restent sans
salaire
ce sont les banqueroutes des pme et la
baisse des revenus des gens alors pour
l'éviter dans certaines régions on
prévoit la vaccination obligatoire
on le sait très bien et on le répète
toujours à la télévision sur internet
dans tous les médias ont utilisé tous
les chaînes d'information pour éviter la
diffusion de l'épisode l'épidémie il n'y
a qu'une seule voie
la vaccination nous avons cette
possibilité parce que nous avons quatre
vaccins et qui sont hautement
technologiques très sécurisée et
efficace et j'espère que certaines
certaine retenue de nos gens vont
disparaître actuellement nous avons
vacciné environ 23 millions de personnes
et tout va très bien il n'y a pas de
situation tragique après la vaccination
comme astrazeneca après astrazeneca est
désert je comprends on m'a demandé de ne
pas indiquer le nom du vaccin pour nous
mais pour ne pas créer des avantages de
concurrence d'un vaccin par rapport à un
autre
mais il y à toutes sortes de questions
là dessus concernant la vidéo je ne
pense pas que c'est très important
montrer cette vidéo peut-être ce n'était
pas une piqûre dans la région d'un bras
parfois il y à des dérogations quand on
utilise non pas le vaccin ou bien une
autre solution qui n'est pas un vaccin
mais je crois que la majorité de
citoyens ne croient si je dis que je me
suis fascinée ça c'est la vérité je ne
suis pas un escroc quand même mais en ce
qui me concerne quand je me suis vacciné
c'était au mois de février et il y a eu
deux vaccins disponibles
et puis vint corona du centre de
novossibirsk et
et ce but nick wey ce sont les deux
vaccins qui sont très bien
actuellement nous en nous en avons
quatre bien bien sûr je pouvais choisir
entre plusieurs vaccins mais j'ai même
pas consulté le vexer les médecins j'ai
regardé qu'est ce que mes connaissances
font par exemple spoutnik vs un vaccin
synthétique mais j'ai vu que les gens
que je connaissais utiliser toutes
sortes de vaccins et j'ai pris la
décision
oui il y a des avantages de différents
vaccins et il n'y a pas d'effets
secondaires
il n'y a pas même pas de montée de
température corporelle d'autres effets
secondaires non plus je partais du fait
quand même que j'ai besoin d'être
protégés à long terme et j'ai choisi
spoutnik mais c'était ma décision
d'ailleurs les forces armées utiliser
spoutnik vais et chez nous et je répète
après la première injection
j'ai rien senti quatre heures après j'ai
senti quelque chose une sorte
de sensibilité dans la région de piqûres
et deuxième chose à minuit j'ai pris ma
température s'était 37,2 mais le matin
c'était déjà 36 et 6 et 7 où il ya rien
quelques jours après une quinzaine de
jours une vingtaine de jours et j'ai
quand même testé il ya eu le prélèvement
du sang et est ce que vous vous êtes
faut vacciner alors ça parce que je
viens d'être malade il faut six mois la
maladie la protection la protection
naturelle
vous savez le mystère de la santé et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
encore recommandé il ya encore quelques
jours la émis des recommandations donc
déjà qu'il n'ya pas de pandémie il ya
des recommandations visant à assurer une
ré vaccination et puis notamment quand
il ya des pics les pandémies et à ce
moment là il faut augmenter la fréquence
de ces vaccins sur internet ce qui se
passe ce genre super oui il ya des gens
qui sont confrontés à des infections qui
sont en puissante et à peu près 10% sont
effectivement à ce moment assez
gravement malade
mais d'une manière générale la maladie
passe relativement légèrement c'est ça
qui est important aujourd'hui parce que
quelqu'un qui n'a pas été vaccinés mais
plus de temps à se remettre et les
conséquences sont plus important
qu'elles peuvent être même un grave et
donc il faut être vigilant vis-à-vis de
sa santé
et beaucoup de gens vont se ruer pour
faire se faire vacciner par spéculer
mais pas tous il y a des gens qui
doutent sur l'efficacité parce qu'ils se
demandent si ça protège de nouvelles
souches
oui je viens de le dire c'est à dire que
c'est à peu près 10% c'est une messe et
un chiffre en moyenne mais je le répète
à ce moment là si on a déjà été
vaccinées la maladie passe au de façon
relativement légère je vais pas citer de
nom de famille aujourd'hui donc il ya
des personnes qui sont célèbres en
russie est encore quelques jours un de
mes collègues était gravement malade qui
a été malade simplement et hier il
faisait déjà que c'était passé donc
parmi mes proches certains ont été
vaccinées pu malade mais en fait ils ont
été malades de façon légère et certains
dont ils n'ont pas été vaccinés au
contraire on était gravement malade donc
la vaccination a lieu d'être
et vous savez que au kremlin nous avons
organisé des remises de médailles et de
décoration pour les personnes qui ont
été héros du travail et notamment des
scientifiques qui ont travaillé à
l'élaboration des vaccins et j'ai des
nouvelles qui viennent régulièrement
oui c'est hier que la maladie elle peut
être grave et c'est surtout les
conséquences les conséquences éloignées
qui peuvent être graves
donc il faut être vigilant là dessus
vous comprenez il ya toujours il ya
toujours été des gens qu'il faut faire
aucun vaccin
il ya des gens qui existe c'est pas
qu'ils aient des dissidents et sont
assez nombreux dans notre pays comme à
l'étranger
mais ce que disent les spécialistes
c'est que quand la vaccination se fait
dans une large ampleur en gros tout
devient à peu près normale et certaines
personnes considèrent qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de se relaxer et des queues
ce seuil minimum redescend on voit une
réapparition des événements et donc les
gens se dépêche d'aller se faire
vacciner
donc il faut suivre ici non pas ceux qui
ne s'y connaissent pas beaucoup n'ont
pas les rumeurs
mais il faut écouter les spécialistes et
il y en a dans le monde entier j'ai tout
entendu il ya des gens qui ont dit que
y'a rien n'y a pas de malade il n'y a
pas de pandémie qui existent voit des
gens cultivés intelligents adultes alors
il y en a qui disent oui alors voyez les
ça se passe dans tout le monde donc il
voyait toutes ces contradictions qui a
pas d'enfants dans le monde
mais attention ça c'est une autre
question est-ce que l'origine est
artificiel ou naturel ça c'est une autre
question
la question aujourd'hui c'est se
protéger de cela si quelqu'un est malade
et comment faire pour se sentir bien
pourtant et est donc vous vous êtes
jeune et vous êtes en bonne forme mais
il ya des gens qui ont d'autres
complexion qui sont sujets à d'autres
maladies il ya d'autres catégories d'âge
et là aussi ce sont des questions de
dangerosité pour certaines catégories de
population donc il ya des gens qui
disent qu'ils la majorité des gens
supporter ma fille aussi a été vaccinée
moi j'ai pas eu de fortes températures
bon bon 37 et quelques pendant une
journée ça va c'est supportable
fonctionné aujourd'hui nous avons reçu 2
millions d'appels
les gens continuent d'écrire d'envoyer
leurs messages nous les réclusion et
nous les partageons un sujet voici les
sujets clés qui intéresse pourront
choisir n'importe quel
sujet et à savoir ce qui intéresse nos
spectateurs par exemple santé publique
tout le monde est préoccupé par la lutte
contre qu'ovide par le déroulement de la
vaccination par l'accessibilité des
médicaments
oui on peut prendre n'importe quel que
bloc de questions sur le sujet
vaccination contre khalid je voudrais
attirer votre attention en bas de
l'écran
nous voyons des districts fédéraux dont
pourront choisir n'importe quel voir de
quelle île il ya des messages
il faut aussi dire que nous avons des
types de messages différents ya des
vidéos des textes des appels des directs
aussi je vous propose de lancer une
message vidéo depuis moscou a les yeux
très bien bonjour j'ai gagné de cette
coupe moscou bonjour bonjour olivier
travaille comme institutrice dans une
école de moscou elle ne peut pas se
faire vacciner à cause d'une maladie
chronique mais le directeur de l'école
n'accepte pas ce document cette
exemption médicale et exige d'eux
propose de présenter des documents sur
la vaccination avant le 15 juillet ma
femme ne peut pas le faire sinon on
menace c'est illégal
je vous le dis tout de suite c'est légal
s'il y a des dérogations pour des
raisons médicales
personne n'a le droit d'imposer une
vaccination
donc le directeur de l'école ou au
travail votre épouse
il n'est peut-être pas au courant et
j'espère qu'il entendra cette réponse
donc ça c'est une exigence de la loi
pour des questions à ce sujet je vois
aussi un message de personnes lui vide
et on lui a dit qu'il y avait une
réhabilitation gratuite dans trois
institutions dans l'eau n'y avait pas de
4 quotas dans l'autre il fallait payer
50 mille roubles
qu'est-ce qui peut répondre moi aussi je
reconnais qu'il ya des solutions
et justement nous travaillons là-dessus
organisons ce travail en fait il s'agit
un travail de convalescence de
réhabilitation qui est un facteur de
santé publique après ma maladie donc
qu'ils n'étaient pas organisées jusqu'au
bout oui il ya eu des sanatoriums à
l'époque soviétique qui travaillent plus
comme des hôtels que pour la
réhabilitation des gens après maladie
oui enfin il y avait d'autres maladies
et d'ailleurs l'époque de l'urss il y
avait un système de vaccination
quasiment strict est obligatoire à
l'époque une personne ne pose deux
questions là dessus alors à l'époque ont
piqué tout le monde et et moi aussi
comme tout le monde
deux étaient dans une famille d'ouvriers
simple donc oui personne ne posait de
questions je l'aï eu je n'ai pas posé de
questions et on m'a pas posé de question
donc voilà donc tout le monde se faisait
vacciner pic pic pic mais la situation
était stable de sur le plan sanitaire
après l'effondrement de l'urss et on a
eu donc l'effondrement du système de
protection sociale et notamment sur sa
forme de points que nous discutons là
aujourd'hui
donc un certain nombre de grands fonds
vont être accordées justement au système
de réhabilitation et de convalescence
est justement actuellement nous signons
des contrats sur l'acquisition de
matériel et d'installation pour la
réhabilitation des gens qui ont été
atteints du coc vide qu'il s'agisse des
organes de
respiration de circulation sanguine etc
donc il faut du matériel spécialisé et
nous avons donc des ressources qui ont
été affectée spécifiquement là dessus je
n'entre pas dans les détails mais en
tout cas il faut regarder ce cas concret
mais en tout cas nous allons trouver des
solutions oui on peut aller mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que les ressources
dédiées à la création de ce système de
réhabilitation de convalescence on était
déjà fait merci notre centre de
traitement est vraiment débordé des
questions ici nous avons des messages de
moscow ici la personne ne s'est pas
encore présentée il ya beaucoup de
questions sur la vaccination je sais
qu'ici nous avons une question vidéo
depuis moscou également de caterina
catch à la barre nous allons voir la
vidéo qui nous a envoyé les ultimes
appels yekaterina moscou j'avais
l'intention de me faire vacciner contre
colis 19 malheureusement dans les points
de vaccination les médecins n'ont pas pu
répondre à la question si mes maladie
était une contre indication pour faire
vacciner pour je peux connaître ma
température chez moi et mesurer la
tension mais
je n'irai pas si je suis dans un mauvais
état mais où est ce que je pourrais
avoir une aide qu'elle est fier et les
réponses à mes questions
quelles peuvent être les risques et
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
dans la vaccination est après
l'accession merci quant à la réponse est
très simple il ya une question
superficielle si vous avez des maladies
qui sont notamment chronique
si vous les connaissez vous avez donc un
contact avec un médecin qui est votre
médecin traitant et c'est lui qu'il faut
voir c'est lui qui doit vous donner une
réponse précise si vous êtes sujette à
vaccination ou pas des rien de plus
simple un côté a dit qu' elle s'était
adressée aux points de vaccination mais
effectivement eux ils ont peut-être pas
l'information ce sont des gens qui sont
des infirmières
il s'agit ici d'un spécialiste précise
que c'est le médecin traitant de la
personne et c'est lui qui doit pouvoir
dire s'il faut faire une vaccination ou
pas il doit y répondre de façon précise
vous avez encore des messages
bonjour monsieur poutine
je m'appelle sacha maximum je suis élève
de troisième année de l'école va 76,17
de moscou trois mois plus tard dans
trois mois la nouvelle année commence la
nouvelle année scolaire comment nous
allons procéder
à l'école ou chez nous merci ça je peux
pas te répondre concrètement je vais pas
te dire tout de suite parce que la
réponse complète elle viendra plus tard
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas comment la
situation va évoluer avec la l'épidémie
du coronavirus dans le pays là où tu vis
en même temps tac ta question est claire
elle est importante
le plus probable c'est que les enfants
des premières classes
il est probable qu'ils iront à l'école
puisque la plupart des écoles
maternelles n'ont pas fermé au cours du
printemps dernier donc le plus probable
est que la rentrée pour les 1re année se
fera selon les modalités habituelles
après il faudra voir concrètement la
situation sur place
mais en tout cas j'espère que malgré
tout nous aurons atteint une certaine
immunité collective qui fait que les
écoles les établissements d'enseignement
les entreprises notamment les pme
pourront travailler de façon normale
vous avez une maintenant seulement
contrôlée bolide mais aussi je pense
contre des pays qui ne sont pas amis une
question que nous avons reçu par texto
pourquoi le cren ne fait pas partie de
la liste des pays amis comme os quoi
encore une question est ce que vous
allez rencontrer monsieur élèves qui
écoute et pourquoi le cren ne fait pas
partie et depuis aussi les parce que je
n'estime pas que le peuple ukrainien
c'est un peuple aussi là pour nous j'ai
gelé dit à maintes reprises je considère
que les russes et les ukrainiens c'est
un seul peuple
écoutez les juifs en arrivant en israël
d'afrique d'europe les noirs d'afrique
bien en israël par exemple et les juifs
les juifs européens qui ne maîtrisent
pas l'hébreu mais le peuple juif estime
que c'est un seul peuple
nous avons par exemple une ethnie comme
les mordre à en russie airria moksha et
d'autres ethnies qui vivent à mort dhabi
mais toutes ces ethnies se considère
comme un seul peuple un peuple mort
d'ordre c'est un seul groupe ethnique
mais dia et moxa parlent les langues
différentes puisque il ya peut-être plus
de différence contre la langue russe et
la langue ukrainienne mais il se
considère comme étant une seule ethnie
pourquoi parceque ils sont intelligents
et ils comprennent que la division c'est
pas bien cela ait faibli un peuple mais
il ya aussi des facteurs externes
le peuple russe et était toujours en
proie des tentatives de division
puisque même à l'époque au la pologne a
fait là l'agression contre la russie
ensuite autriche hongrie à l'époque de
la première guerre mondiale
mr on voudrait le comprendre et on doit
le comprendre il ya eu une grand de
russie
il y a la petite russie est ce l'effet
de facteurs externes et l'activité des
bolchéviques peut être il ya eu une
division d'un peuple russe unique
malheureusement on ne peut pas entrer en
dtm et je vais écrire un article là
dessus ça sera un article analytique et
j'espère qu'en russie et connu cren on
va lire cet article et je vais donc
expliquer mon point de vue mais bien sûr
personne ne s'y intéresse les gens sont
confinés dans leur propre mort de mais
je ne crois pas que le peuple ukrainien
c'est un peuple aussi la russie non pas
du tout nous faisons un ensemble tandis
que les autorités ukrainiennes actuelle
ce
occupe une position hostile envers la
russie ça c'est évident sinon comment
expliquer pourquoi il propose un projet
de loi à la rade est radin qui concerne
les peuples autochtones où il considère
que le peuple russe n'est pas un peuple
autochtone sur le territoire ukrainien
c'est inconcevable depuis des
millénaires les russes vivent sur le
territoire ukrainien
et cela va amener la situation où
beaucoup de gens vont partir mais ou
partir ils n'ont pas de logement ils
n'ont pas de travail alors il pourrait
peut-être changer des têtes ni de
nationalité et cela va amener à la
réduction du nombre de russes c'est on
peut le comparer avec l'effet d'une arme
de destruction massive c'est très
sérieux c'est très grave
on supprime la langue russe dans la vie
quotidienne
et vous savez partout il ya des
nationalistes des gens têtus même c'est
en russie en ukraine par tous et ces
gens là sont peut-être sincère mais ne
sont pas intelligents et leur action est
centrée destructive
ils font pression sur l'opposition en
ukraine
monsieur métais tube par exemple c'est
un nationalistes ukrainiens qui était
écroué et durant la campagne électorale
on prend des décisions qui sont est
inconstitutionnel et illégal et personne
n'y fait attention à l'intérieur de ce
pays on fait croire qu'il n'ya pas de
possibilité légale et pour ceux qui
veulent construire
des relations normales avec la russie
ils n'ont pas de chance ces gens là
puisqu'ils sont oppressés écroué en
prison massacrés dans la rue à quoi bon
nous rencontrer avec monsieur alinsky 6
et l'ukraine sous l'autorité de céline
ce qu'ils sont contrôlés de l'extérieur
est les aspects clés de la vie en
ukraine sont décidées à washington à
berlin à paris mais bien sûr je ne
renonce pas à ces rencontres là mais je
veux comprendre a de quoi on va parler
de quoi
qui a parlé de sa femme qui suit un v6
se faire l'essentiel parce qu'on peut
montrer la pelle qui porte sur un autre
sujet mais proche de la laisser à
l'hésitation
après kobe de omsk silva silcoff non ça
ne marche pas malheureusement on n'a pas
réussi des mais ça arrive mais on va y
revenir peut-être pas c'est un centre du
traitement des messages
tetiana vous êtes là oui chers collègues
merci nous avons traité des dizaines des
milliers des questions nous avons
précisé des détails rappeler les gens
dans le top 5 des sujets c'est
l'économie la croissance des prix si on
met le mont pris dans notre base de
connaissances des milliers de messages
il ya un message vidéo qui est fait dans
le magasin de produits
on va le regarder si vous voulez on l'a
dit me en numéro 8 dites moi s'il vous
plaît comment se fait-il que les bananes
de l'équateur ici chez nous coûte moins
cher que les carottes qui viennent des
régions voisines
voici le prix et pour les pommes de
terre aussi la question de la question
d'où vient ce prix là comme à la
confiance le prix c'est combien
avec le minimum de paiements avec ce
genre de prix pour les produits ce que
quelqu'un contrôler les prix en russie
où les prix n'arrive par eux-mêmes qui
invente le prix et on peut le fixer un
peu le m si j'ai bien noté les carottes
c'était 110 roubles les bananes 70 et le
beurre 500 l'huile 500-600 les bananes
écouter aujourd'hui les indices des prix
alimentaires sont au sommet depuis dix
ans oui il y à la montée des prix
alimentaires partout dans le monde et
bien sûr puisque la russie fait partie
de l'économie globale
nous le ressentons et il ya beaucoup de
cause il y à l'émission de des monnaies
dans les pays principaux principaux
également les conséquences de la
pandémie est là
réduction des emplois et j'en passe la
plus grande hausse des prix alimentaires
a été constatée l'année dernière et au
début de cette année
il s'agit du sucre par exemple 40 1%
l'huile de tournesol et vous savez
peut-être que nous avons donné des
explications le gouvernement a pris des
décisions là dessus pour contenir les
prix alimentaires
certaines mesures ont été prises
il y a eu une sorte de contrat entre les
fabricants et les réseaux de
distribution
deuxième mesure d il y a eu l'aide
financier pour les producteurs
nous avons introduit dans le commerce
extérieur des taxes douanières plus
élevé et il s'agit aussi d'autres
mesures en général l'état fait attention
à ce problème peut être de façon qui
n'est pas opportune et j'en ai parlé
avec le gouvernement mais nous prenons
des mesures concernant le prix du beurre
500-600 les prix de lait sont assez
stables
et puisque le beurre est fabriqué à base
du lait il y à la hausse des prix du
beurre qui constitue 3,5 1 5%
c'est moins que le taux d'inflation
puisque l'inflation constitue environ à
environ 6% 5,9 pour cent
néamoins ce problème persiste je
l'avouer et valentina no
explique qu' il y à une sorte d'
ensemble de produits qui qui sont
nécessaires il ya la carotte il ya des
pommes de terre il y a les ruptures de
stock
concernant les pommes de terre
l'année dernière c'était 12 que le 5
millions de tonnes cette année là nous
attendons à 20 2 millions de tonnes de
pommes de terre c'est largement
suffisant et pour le moment nous
procédons à des exportations et des
importations d'oeufs bio la russie et de
turquie où il y a le climat le plus
propice pour cultiver les pommes de
terre et il faut voir quels sont les
problèmes de logistique comment combien
ça coûte
le transport du produit mais je le
répète
nos bientôt nous allons avoir une
nouvelle récolte de légumes et ça c'est
une grande question quand nous
développons l'agriculture les légumes
les fruits
pour le moment il y a le manque de
légumes de fruits pour la consommation
intérieure
par exemple les viandes bovines et la
viande de volaille
ça va ça ne suffit même nous procédons à
d'exportation puisque l'année dernière à
nous avons nous avons gagné grâce aux
exportations
un chiffre record 30 milliards de
dollars c'est inédit
les exportations de blé également cela
nous permet de contenir les prix du pain
il y adéquate à daix des exportations
des taxes douanières et cette hausse des
prix du pain l'huile de tournesol
constitue uniquement 0,1 pour cent le
prix du sucre également le même chiffre
c'est à dire que nous procédons aux
mesures de règlement de régulation et
qui donnent leurs effets mais
malheureusement pas pour toutes les
catégories de produits
on revient à d'autres questions et on
revient à omsk
vadimir aleksic excuses en résumé alex
ich nous vous entendons nous écoutons
bonjour
j'ai travaillé pendant plus de 40 ans et
j'ai reçu le titre de vétéran de
travailler dans la région de homs que
maintenant on m'a rajouté un peu
elle est tellement de retraités mais on
m'a privé des privilèges alors c'est
comme s'il m'avait vraiment un trail
vous avez envoyé la question sur la
réhabilitation après qu vide
oui ça aussi c'était mes questions oui à
l'isi en ce qui concerne le statut de
d'anciens du travail je sais de vétérans
du travail je sais que beaucoup de gens
dans les régions sont confrontés à ce
problème et c'est une décision qui est
au niveau régional c'est à dire que
quand ces titres ont été attribués et
les régions prennent des décisions
concernant pour priver les gens de ce
statut et je sais que c'est absolument
pas le justifier
et je suis bien d'accord avec vous que
c'est une décision qui est absolument
injuste et j'espère que je serai entendu
à omsk lui il ya une règle générale qui
d'ailleurs prévu par la constitution
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas priver
les gens des titres et des avantages
liés à ce titre
dont ils ont bénéficié et je prie tous
les dirigeants région j'y reviens au
sujet de l'agriculture et on va voir
quelles sont les questions qui viennent
de ceux qui sont dans l'agriculture la
ville d'oufa par exemple abbas qui rit
il y à la sécheresse c'est une vraie
catastrophe
c'est un grand problème s'il vous plaît
apportez votre attention les problèmes
d'amélioration jeu premièrement je dois
dire que l'agriculture est un secteur
qui fait que nous avons des raisons
d'être fiers aujourd'hui puisque
l'export est aujourd'hui c'est des
résultats absolument stupéfiant
impressionnant la productivité augmente
le volume des productions augmente sur
les fruits encore du travail à faire
l'immédiat besoin d'être ici et l'aide
que nous apportons c'est quand même 350
milliards de roubles de chiffre
d'affaires général il ya encore 35
milliards qui ont été orientés vers
l'amélioration des services sociaux aux
nuits dans le haut niveau rural et 70
milliards pour classer des terres en
catégorie arables et donc c'est ce sont
des fonds qui sont attribués chaque
année donc il y a un programme lié à
l'amélioration des sols ici et nous
allons continuer cette politique
l'amélioration des sols et importante
compte tenu des changements climatiques
nous allons poursuivre ces efforts les
renforcer je voudrais citer quelques
messages ont dit qu'il y aura une
un taxe sur le bétail gens se demandent
dans la région de rostov se demande si
ça peut peut être possible sur mais il
n'y a pas de taxer pour l'instant est
encore question dans ce sujet posé par
an si terre de gauche qui qui s'occupe
de débris by sélectionné et il demande
de l'aide pour avoir des terrains à
nazran
en ce qui concerne l'aide à apporter je
vais en parler avec le dirigeant de la
république et d'une manière générale
dans le caucase du nord
c'est important c'est une valeur
particulière et à partir du moment où
cette personne travaille là-dessus et
c'est important puisque il travaille
dans la sélection des brebis et c'est un
sujet sur lesquels nous attribuons de
plus en plus d'importance
il s'agit des semences du bétail
c'est un travail qui est important et
nous n'en sommes encore qu'aux premiers
pas dans cette direction mais c'est
important ne savent pas que évidemment
nous travaillons dans ce domaine mais
pour que
les poules grandissons n'importe des
oeufs de qualité en ce qui concerne les
bovidés les ovidés encore une fois c'est
une orientation sur laquelle nous
travaillons et donc la personne qui
travaille dans ce domaine dans le
domaine de la sélection doit être aidé
donc la première partie de votre
question
c'était alors l'impôt sur le bétail
l'impôt par tête
non il n'y a aucun impôt sur le bétail
personne n'a prévu d'introduire un tel
impôt j'espère que je suis entendu pas
seulement rostov mais dans toutes les
régions de russie sans cesse et que les
mystères croyez moi il est hors de
question de prévoir une telle
ce sont des rumeurs je propose de
continuer avec le sujet de l'économie
nous avons sujet industrie et production
voir qui sont les messages et appels
dans ce sens nous avons trié troïtski
recevoir les mails ou imaginaires ça
m'est égal
ces risques ou kiêu
bonjour bonjour monsieur poutine je suis
très contente de vous voir ma question
je m'appelle cette nana et donc ma
question porte sur la croissance des
prix la croissance énorme sur les
matériaux de construction en exemple
nous avons eu un petit appartement de 33
mètres carrés et cette année nous avons
voulu améliorer nos conditions de
logement nous avons acheté un terrain en
lots de terrain et nous sommes en train
de planifier la construction
le coût pour entourer le
le terran c'est 260 mille roubles
seulement pour la barrière et nous
voyons qu'il ya un prix est très élevé
et je voudrais comprendre au nom de
famille qui se retrouve dans la même
situation
est ce que les prix vont rester à ce
niveau est ce qu'ils vont encore
augmenter
ou peut être grâce à votre aide les prix
seront plus accessibles pour regarder
j'espère que mon aide
fera en sorte que ces produits seront
plus accessibles
il ya plusieurs aspects ici scellier
déjà avec évidemment avec les récoltes
on a une inflation qui était de l'ordre
de 4% et qui est aujourd'hui en gros à
5,9 pour cent
et aujourd'hui on a pour objectif de
réduire cette inflation et c'est pour ça
que la banque centrale a réhaussé c'est
tout
c'est des ses taux directeurs ça c'est
un point important de l'économie et
j'espère que cette inflation reviendra
au niveau fixé de 4%
je pense que rapidement c'est rare que
nous c'est peu preuve que nous puissions
mais je pense que nous devrions pouvoir
réussir à être autour de 5% et nous
avons nous allons essayer de maintenir
ce niveau avec une tendance à la baisse
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
c'est lié à quoi cela je pense que c'est
questions vont probablement ressurgir
dans notre discussion aujourd'hui il y à
une conjoncture mondiale sur les prix
des produits que ce soit lé le métal par
exemple donc par exemple les prix sur
les métaux les prix des métaux ont
augmenté au niveau mondial ça a été la
même chose pour le sucre est évidemment
nos producteurs de sucre ont suivi la
tendance mondiale c'est la même chose
avec les métaux donc on a une
augmentation mondiale et nous essayons
de
nous producteurs essaient d'être au
niveau mondial et tout ce qui est lié à
cela
tôt ou tard connaît aussi une
augmentation donc des décisions sont
prises au niveau gouvernemental
aujourd'hui pour maintenir les maintenir
les prix à des niveaux normaux
je sais que le secteur du btp est touché
par ça aussi nous prenons des décisions
pour que la situation reste stable à ce
propos alors il faut réfléchir et vous
vendez votre appartement c'est ça alors
pour ceux pour ceux qui vendent leur
appartement en tout cas les gens ont vu
que et se tient le remarquer récemment
au niveau du parti aussi unis nous en
avons parlé si la personne vendant les
cinq ans son appartement et pour en
racheter un autre la personne paient un
impôt sur le bénéfice
compte tenu de l'augmentation des prix
et l'immobilier les gens pouvaient
perdre finalement donc ici une question
de premier rapport pour l'achat d'un
appartement
donc ce que je propose c'est que on ne
nous oblige pas à ces gens qu'ils
revendent leur appartement à payer donc
évidemment vous ça vous concerne
- mais ce simplement qu'ils veulent
donc il ya ceux qui veulent améliorer
leurs conditions de vie simplement
revendre dans l'appartement mais nous
allons chercher à stabiliser les prix
sur le marché
mais il ya aussi d'autres mesures qui
sont liées à l'infrastructure autres
eddy d'infrastructures sur les charges
locatives etc
mais tout cela doit faire en sorte que
toutes ces mesures doit faire en sorte
que les prix se stabilisent et je vous
souhaite en tout cas que vos plans se
réalise
merci c'est réciproque
nous ne sommes pas seulement regarder
par fos par des téléspectateurs pour son
gouvernement
madame golikova vient de dire que vous
avez cités 10% des personnes qui sont
malades après le vaccin
oui 2,5 pour ça à qui il faut croire
merci tatiana golikova pour cette
information effectivement évidemment
elle travaille journellement sur cette
question en sur la question de la santé
publique je sais de quoi elle parle elle
sait de quoi elle parle
la question posée à tous les gouverneurs
d'avoir des lignes directes comme chez
vous chaque année au shaq qui trimestre
cela en aurait eu nombre de questions de
celles qui vous ont posé il ya certains
gouverneurs qui ont fait ça à moscou et
à saint pétersbourg
je pense que ça ne peut faire de mal à
personne
ce genre de discussion en direct est
importante pas seulement parce que les
gens de s'adresser à la première
personne de l'état ou de la région mais
aussi parce que et sa gelée souvent dit
on a en fait une sélection qui se fait
des thèmes prioritaires pour la
population ces importantes
ça nous permet de corriger notre
activité pratique journalière sur les
domaines importante qu'il s'agisse du
travail
du logement de la santé publique et moi
effectivement je recommanderai aux
responsables régionaux d'écouter l'avis
de la population
certaines questions très simples ne peut
pas être résolue sans gouvernail
oui ça arrive il faut évidemment tendre
à faire en sorte que tout fonctionne de
façon automatique
en tout cas ce contact cet aller retour
il doit exister c'est aller retour c'est
vrai que l'année a été difficile surtout
[Musique]
libérer certains entrepreneurs
oui enfin dans certaines conditions
c'est à dire que tout soit clair
transparent et que tout passe par la
caisse et que les produits achetés par
eux qui ne sont pas utilisés
passe aussi en comptabilité en
interprétant le domaine de restauration
publique directe maxime hubiche oui je
vous entends monsieur poutine
bonjour bonjour maxime je voudrais vous
poser question en tant qu après
représentant un interpréteur je me suis
adressé pour avoir en soutien financier
avoir un crédit
plusieurs fois pour développer le
business mais les conditions qui auront
été proposés par des organisations de
crédit ne nous permettent pas de
nouvelles mais pas d'une manière
efficace ce sont deux des taux très
élevé de 18% des délais de jusqu'à trois
ans délai très court
il y a il faut aussi payer une certaine
somme de sécurité et cela ne permet pas
d'avoir un soutien financier et de
focaliser les finances des moyens pour
développer les interprètes les
entrepreneurs et des compagnies qui
pourrait faire le socle de notre
économie est ce que le gouvernement
considère un moyen de soutenir d'une
manière efficace le gouverneur dans ces
questions là notamment d'augmenter les
délais de réduire le taux est de nous
libérer des sommes qu'on paie en tant
que caution
c'est ce qui est nécessaire pour le
business heures voici donc ma question
maxime votre question n'est pas du tout
veine je la comprends bien
elle est importante les pme les petites
entreprises les très petites entreprises
ou ont des difficultés financières et
c'est particulièrement important et dans
les conditions de la pandémie
évidemment ce sont les pme qui ont le
plus souffert
on en est bien conscient j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que nous avons
pris le gouvernement a pris un certain
nombre de mesures pour aider les pme
qu'il s'agisse de crédit à taux
préférentiel de
délai de remboursement etc de maintien
de l'emploi
et c'est tout un ensemble de mesures que
nous avons prises
encore une fois sur les délais de
remboursement sur les taux de crédit etc
et c'est vraiment un ensemble de mesures
très complet que nous avons prise ce que
vous avez dit c'est important maxime je
vous comprends bien mais pour organiser
ce travail sans notamment sans les âges
dégage par exemple après comment vous
allez rembourser cet argent je comprends
que tout cela est il faut pas non plus
casser le système bancaire ici parce que
le système bancaire évidemment reçoivent
beaucoup d'argent mais les décisions à
prendre qui permettrait en fait
[Musique]
d'assurer la stabilité de cette plate
forme c'est un sujet très délicat parce
qu'il faut map à matran en faut pas
mettre en danger ce système vous avez
18% ce sale je suis d'accord avec vous
que c'est un taux très élevé parce que
en moyenne chez nous il est normalement
de 12% pour les entreprises pour les
micro crédits
il ya aussi des formes avec certains
avantages
est ce que l vous ont été protégés parce
que les crédits à taux préférentiels
existe il ya évidemment le taux
directeur de la banque centrale qui est
de 5 5% +2 7 75% qui sont ajoutés ça
nous fait 8
25% on est quand même très loin des 12 %
ou des 18%
donc nous avions l'année dernière prend
pris un certain nombre de mesures
notamment sur les fonds budgétaires pour
que pour aider la population et les gens
ont reçu en gros un mille milliards de
roubles
donc il y a effectivement un besoin
nécessaire
maxime nous allons continuer à
développer ce système
c'est une question de possibilités
budgétaires ici ou de restrictions
budgétaires 18% je suis bien conscient
que c'est beaucoup
laissez vos coordonnées
nous avons tous ces données normalement
les collègues ou vos coordonnées on va
essayer de voir avec qui et quelle
banque vous avez travaillé qu'elles sont
des instruments
vous pourriez utiliser et qui aurait pu
vous être pu vous être proposés on va
regarder ça je vous propose de passer à
un autre sujet la défense et la sécurité
c'est un sujet assez chaud parce que
dans les sujets ne peuvent pas être
différent dans ce sens voici un message
depuis krasnoïarsk
bonjour monsieur poutine bonjour juste
pas je m'appelle le bundle est bas je
pense que ma question est d'actualité
pour beaucoup de gens jusqu'où les
fraudes
les échos de par téléphone vont
continuer à leur activité
ils se disent fonctionnaires des banques
ou d'autres organisations et volent les
moyens personnes les plus fragiles dont
les retraités et les vieux quand ils
sont découverts
il envoie des menaces par des textos
jusqu'où ça va continuer je pense qu'il
doit y avoir des moyens techniques grâce
auquel on pourrait les suivre et les
punir protégez nous s'il vous plaît de
ce malheur mercier ce problème apparaît
dans beaucoup de régions par exemple
pendant le défilé militaire près de vous
il y avait en vétérans si hong kong est
en acier les pronine vous avez parlé un
peu et deux semaines après des escrocs
leur voix les volets de cent mille
roubles donc c'est un problème répandu
il à 96 1 écoutez je ne veux pas même
donné des commentaires
ce sont des gens de mauvaise foi
ce sont des ingrats et il faut lutter
contre
ces crimes malheureusement nous
constatons la hausse de la criminalité
dans ce domaine
s'il s'agit des crimes graves
en général la situation est assez
satisfaisante
il y a même une certaine baisse du
nombre de crimes mais dans ce domaine là
nous constatons la hausse de 20 5% de
quelles en sont les causes la première
chose qui crée des conditions propices
pour la hausse des crimes de cette sorte
c'est la circulation illicite de données
personnelles et l'état la police doit
travailler là dessus et en se basant sur
les données personnelles et qui sont
accessibles les criminal procède de
cette façon là il y à toutes sortes de
questions qui nécessitent une grande
attention
d'abord c'est la compétence de la banque
centrale est il faut lutter de façon
plus active contre les sites de phishing
ce sont les sites et qui le fit chine
cesser la pêche vie ici ils recherchent
leurs droits dans sur internet et
auparavant pour fermer ces sites
la banque centrale mettez quelques mois
maintenant cela nécessite trois mois
mais il faut à artix activité ce travail
ensuite les banques commerciales et qui
possède de ses données personnelles et
ils doivent contrôler tous les processus
de transaction pour réduire la
possibilité de crimes de cette sorte
il faut prendre en compte toutes sortes
d'aspects lyubov l'a expliqué les
escrocs s'active dans le domaine du
social
là où il y à des services sociaux qui
sont actives et donc il téléphone il
faut des appels au nom de ses services
sociaux il ya aussi des questions qui
sont à la frontière de la compétence de
la police et de la banque centrale
où est la contradiction là dessus la
banque centrale et les institutions
fonctionnent financières doivent
protéger le secret des dépôts bancaires
mais de l'autre côté les forces de
l'ordre doivent avoir la possibilité à
au stade précoce de prévenir ces crimes
mais aujourd'hui conformément à la loi
qui protège le secret bancaire
il est très difficile d'avoir accès à
ses données personnelles pour la police
seulement sur décision du tribunal mais
il y à une solution
la banque centrale a le droit dans le
cas où il voit des transactions opaques
de saisir la police mais si donc la
banque centrale à ce droit
les services du ministère de l'intérieur
et d'autres forces de l'ordre peuvent
saisir la banque centrale la banque
centrale à son tour à la possibilité de
contrôler et si la banque centrale
estime que cette transaction sont
illicites
dans ce cas et le fournit cette
information aux forces deux autres et il
ya des moyens techniques modernes qui
permettent de le faire hein c'est très
rapide
cela dit il faut utiliser cette solution
et améliorer la pratique de ce travail
et le cadre normatif la question de
l'autre domaine mais peu tous les
combattants
concernant la situation avec le bateau
britannique en crimée non je ne le crois
pas c'est la question que c'est bien
c'est une constatation il y a des
questions à ce sujet si tu l'a dessinée
guerre je vous explique
d'abord ça c'est une provocation c'est
évident qu'est ce qu'elle voulait
montrer quelle était leur objectif de
ces provocateurs
d'ailleurs c'était un ensemble qui est
menée non seulement par les britanniques
mais les américains également parce que
le navire britannique est entré dans les
eaux territoriales de la russie mais à
7h30 sur la drôme montagnards en grèce
un avion de reconnaissance américain a
décollé j'en ai été informé je le savais
très bien c'était le numéro 63 97 92
alors c'était un avion de reconnaissance
qui avait une mission militaire pour
donc recueillir 1 les renseignement de
nos forces navales pour voir comment ça
marche et comment ça fonctionne
alors on le savait très bien et on leur
a fourni quelques renseignements que
nous étions nécessaire peut-être je
révèle un certain secret ensuite il y a
une composante politique bien sûr
notre rendez vous à genève a eu lieu il
y a quelques jours
quel était l'objectif c'est de souligner
que ces gens là ne respecte pas le choix
des habitants de crimée alors vous
pouvez continuer à ne pas reconnaître
mais à quoi bon mener ses provocations
peut-être on se moque un peu de nous
dans le temps parce qu'il y a des les
frégates ou l'envié tout ça je vous
explique
vous dites que le monde était prête à
entamer une nouvelle guerre mondiale non
même si on coule ce navire la guerre ne
se classe pas parce que ceux qui le
commettent le savent ils ne peuvent pas
être vainqueur dans cette guerre c'est
très important et je ne crois pas que on
va on serait très heureux si elle est la
situation prend ce court mais on est sur
notre propre territoire
on lutte pour notre avenir ce n'est pas
nous qui venons sur leur propre
territoire à des milliers de kilomètres
non ils s'approchent de nos propres
frontières
il entre dans nos eaux territoire
territoriale et c'est une composante
très importante mais ce n'est pas ça qui
me préoccupe est même pas que quelqu'un
ne respecte pas le choix des habitants
de crimée et on parlait beaucoup des
extras 6e reçu sur notre territoire
près des frontières il traîne viennent
donc j'ai ordonné au ministère de la
défense de retirer nos troupes précis
que quelqu'un est très préoccupé par le
fait nous l'avons fait mais
faute de réaction positive
comme quoi nous avons très bien compris
votre réaction
au lieu de ça qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
s'approchent de nos frontières
pendant votre message
voilà ça ne l'est fédéral vous avez dit
que c'est un sport de taquiner un peu la
russie donc nous allons essayer de le
faire
non c'est pas ça je répète je n'ai pas
préoccupé par ça je suis préoccupé par
une autre chose des choses plus
fondamental c'est le début de
l'installation sur militaires sur le
territoire du requip d'ukrainiens
oui on peut créer des centres
d'entraînement aux biens d'autres formes
mais s'installe et militairement sur le
territoire ukrainien qui est à la
frontière de la russie
cela crée pour nous des problèmes de
défense des problèmes est grave puisque
des intérêts vitaux de russie sont
touchés ici et c'est ça qui me préoccupe
et nous y réfléchissons je ne prends pas
propose de passer à un autre bloc des
sous groupes de sujets la politique
sociale elle est très liée à l'économie
mais est un peu à part
et je propose de voir quelles questions
nous avons reçu des familles avec des
enfants je vois qu'il ya une vidéo
depuis astra cagnes il y à aussi d'un
message on va voir la vidéo on peut le
faire
bonjour oksana nous est en direct
bonjour monsieur poutine je m'adresse au
nom de toutes les maires de la région
d'astrakhan nous voulons vous poser la
question sur les nouvelles les exigences
concernant
la seule question pour les mineurs de 3
à 7 1 ils tiennent compte des paies des
salaires et cette année a été difficile
beaucoup de gens ont perdu leurs revenus
la région n'a pas et fait une exception
nous avons toujours des problèmes avec
l'emploi ma question est donc celle ci
dans notre région il faut savoir leur
venue pour 12 mois alors que selon le
degré de la fédération de russie sur les
allocations il n'y a pas de tête et
cette exigence concernant douze mois
dans d'autres régions et en seul mois
survenu officiel il suffit pour obtenir
ces à la question pourquoi notre région
interprète d'une manière différente ce
décret et renonce au maire solitaire et
au maire de nombreuses familles
considèrent comme un appartement
l'appartement à la maison comme un
allongement unis qui ne lui dit pas ad
ce qui est pierre d'autres familles et
ils se refaire tout le temps sur le
décret et non pas à des documents
originaux
nous avons saisi le mini mist le
ministère dans d'autres régions abate li
na mais pour savoir et les ministres et
tous ceux qui nous ont répondu on dit
qui il suffisait d'avoir le revenu pour
un mois aidez nous s'il vous plaît de
régler le problème dans notre ministère
il s'agit de la règle de revenus 0
revenus si les gens travaillent et ces
gens ne travaillait pas officiellement
ils ne peuvent pas avoir cette
allocation est ce que vous pouvez
formuler encore une fois vous ne pouvez
pas obtenir cette allocation pourquoi
parce que nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de montrer 12 mois de
revenus or moi cinq mois ça ne suffit
pas ils exigent 12 mois de revenus
conformément au décret gouvernemental on
devrait voir une année entière
oui le revenu annuel dans d'autres
régions il suffit de voir en ce mois de
réunions avec revenus écoutez oksana
si vous avez un excédent durant un mois
de votre revenu ce n'est pas la raison
pour refuser c'est pas illégal mais bon
on devrait voir les données concrètes
vous avez des données concrètes
je vais demander secondes de votre
attention s'il ya oui je vous écoute
cela concerne cette question parce que
les enfants qui n'ont plus d'allocations
cette année parce que les familles non
ne peuvent pas confirmer leur venue pour
qui un mois qu humain qu ils sont privés
de sa location n'ont pas de revenus
saisir le le revenu 00 revenu parce
qu'il ya des gens qui c'est à dire l'île
de châssis une personne ne travaille pas
alors il n'a pas le droit à cette
allocation non la personne n'a travaillé
pendant 11 mois et pendant un mois et
dont on n'a pas travaillé et donc on les
roule jusqu'à ses bases alors il
travaillait dur en hausse et moi et moi
durant un mois il n'a pas travaillé et
donc il n'a pas droit à cette allocation
je vais demander le gouvernement de de
faire l'analyse de cette situation mais
ce qu'on va faire
il faut être enregistrées à la bourse du
travail
dès que vous perdez le travail le
travail et de ce moment là vous aurez le
droit à cette allocation ou la bourse
ait rejeté également donc nous ne savons
pas par quoi commencer parce que c'est
un chaos
oksana je vous dis si vous êtes
enregistré à la bourse du travail vous
aurez le droit à cette allocation sinon
c'est pas illégal dans votre cas
concrets on va analyser la situation je
vais demander le gouvernement de voir
qu'est ce qui se passe mais j'aurais pas
été si vous perdez le travail
enregistrez-vous à la bourse du travail
tout de suite
et dans ce cas personne ne peut vous
refuser cette allocation
j'espère que nos collègues dans votre
région vont réagir de façon adéquate
mais de toute façon je vais demander le
gouvernement et gagnent également
d'annuler cette situation nous espérons
que la justice va régner merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup de soulever cette
question
oui cela concerne 2 les nombreux gens et
là on va apporter des corrections pour
protéger les droits des rues der demande
à qui il arrive très bien cette
situation et pour continuer le sujet du
soutien social pour des familles pendant
cette année de pandémie à partir de
demain certains paiements pourront être
demandées par exemple pour les femmes
enceintes qui se sont trouvés dans une
situation difficile très bien les
parents solitaire ou six la valeur et
des 6es
les enfants commencent à aller à l'école
à partir du mois de doute c'était
marrant ce faire le système at-il tenir
ses charges supplémentaires mais on va
réussir la première année pour ces deux
allocations les femmes enceintes
enregistrés et la deuxième catégorie
nous avons prévu 46 millions de roubles
m et l'année prochaine ce sera encore
plus et là on ne voit aucun problème
hier j'ai parlé avec le ministre des
finances nous avons ses moyens il ya eu
encore une question non résolue pour les
enfants qui vont vont aller à l'école à
l'âge de 7 ans bien à 6 ans mais
quelqu'un va à l'école à l'âge de 6 ans
dans une autre famille
ils vont à l'âge de sept ans alors le
gouvernement nous poser une question ils
vont donc toucher toutes les questions
mais l'enfant ne va pas à l'école à
l'âge de 6 ans mais j'estime et je crois
que le gouvernement va m'entendre
il faut accorder cette location à tout
le monde à toutes les familles où il y a
des enfants de 6 ans même si ces enfants
ne vont pas aller coller cette année
mais je porte l'attention des parents
sur le fait que c'est une allocation
unique et donc si ils touchent cette
allocation même si l'enfant ne va pas à
l'école et cette année alors et cet
argent devrait être utilisée pour
préparer l'enfant pour l'école l'année
prochaine je vous propose de continuer
notre direct de passer dans le centre du
traitement des messages natale et à
youri va merci nous avons des messages
que nous ne pouvons pas ignorer parce
que ce sont de vrais cris de l'âme
je demande les rédacteurs de montrer le
message de ceux de la natte shimizu va
de yaroslavl elle écrit bonjour vladimir
poutine j'habite je vis avec un enfant
de 9 ans je travaille mais pour douze
mille roubles pour comme nettoyeuses et
moi - le crédit et il me reste quatre
mille roubles je n'ai pas de moyens pour
payer les crédits pour acheter des kia
pour mon enfant et je vous demande
d'aider dans les questions des crédits
comprend parce qu'on est dans cet état
on ne peut plus rien faire pour que
cette situation est délicate
je ne réponds ce qu'on prête gens parler
en général
vous voyez que nous avons un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été prises
pour soutenir les gens qui sont dans des
situations de précarité de précarité en
particulier avec des enfants je vais pas
énumérer toutes ces mesures mais
l'ensemble de ces mesures est à ses
valises à ces grands se dire est que
l'essentiel c'est que depuis la
naissance de l'enfance jusqu'à sa
scolarité jusqu'à saf la fin de sa
scolarité toutes les personnes qui sont
en précarité le gouvernement surtout le
telle forme propose un certain nombre de
mesures dont nous avons parlé d'une de
ces mesures est la femme qui se retrouve
par exemple seuls
au début de sa grossesse et cetera il ya
différents types de solutions ça
concerne la scolarité les familles
incomplète et j'espère que madame vous
aurez la possibilité de bénéficier de
ces mesures de ces instruments
en ce qui concerne les crédits ici il y
à un point important qui est concret qui
a été discuté hier à l'initiative de
certains députés de 2oc unis et que je
signais j'ai signé cette loi et ce sont
des mesures qui font que en dehors en
deux en deçà du minimum vital
les citoyens ne peuvent pas se faire
retirer de l'argent pour payer des
crédits et donc les personnes qui sont
en état de précarité comme vous doivent
pouvoir bénéficier de cette aide de
cette protection
je répète encore une fois les mesures
sont nombreuses pour le soutien des
femmes et chez pas signer un petit c'est
un aspect très important ce que je viens
de dire est très important malgré les
crédits les banques n'ont pas le droit
de procéder au retrait d'argent des
comptes de ces personnes si la personne
a des revenus inférieurs au minimum
vital
nous avons eu de tels messages justement
sur lili cros crédible je vous propose
de choisir
la partie divers faits divers au
personnel nous avons en appel le voit la
star au double bonjour monsieur poutine
je m'appelle alexandre ismayilov de la
ville de stara douche je voudrais vous
poser la question quel lesquels de vos
rêves ne peuvent plus être réalisés
merci alexandre il me semble que chacun
vraiment chaque personne vous moi
les jolies jeunes femmes qui nous
entoure
tous ceux qui nous écoutent nous avons
tous le devoir de penser à ce qu'ils
aient de meilleurs et ce qu'on peut
attendre
et évidemment c'est toujours lié d'une
certaine mesure liée à nos rêves je
pense que c'est votre cas c'est mon cas
et il n'y a pas d'état dans lequel la
personne ne rêve pas à quelque chose
donc je pense qu'il faut effectivement
avoir une humeur positive
quel que soit le rêve il c'est possible
l'essentiel c'est de ne pas arrêter de
rêver
oui on dit par exemple oui si on le veut
vraiment on l'aura et donc il faut
penser aux choses positives et alors ça
se concrétise espérant que tout ira bien
et que coville va disparaître de notre
vie passe
ça va pas ça va pas passer tout seul il
faut se faire vacciner pour cela nous
allons écouter votre recommandation donc
par cette technique
oui comme on a compris non non pas
forcément pas forcément si le président
a choisi spoutnik ok vous êtes en bonne
santé
je le répète encore et puis va colonna
[Musique]
qui ne se signalaient pas tout à fait
sécurisé donc nous n'y a pas de réaction
aucun vaccin usine ils sont tous
inoffensif c'est important nous avons
encore la partie 1 strass structures et
services communaux il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes
surtout concernant l'approvisionnement
en gaz c'est un sujet qui a toujours été
actuel pour les régions après votre
initiative sur la réduction des coûts de
début de l'approvisionnement par des
tubes baisse de tarif mais du dernier
kilomètre
on va voir à quelles demandes nous avons
à ce sujet quelle question nous avons
ici la crimée karatchaïevo tcherkessie
ya d'autres régions alors l'ordinateur
ne me ne m'écoute pas vraiment qui va
gagner la technique que moi je ne sais
pas on peut choisir
il ya beaucoup de messages divers sur la
gazéification et puis il est juste sur
le bouton des explications histo appuyer
sur le bouton l'admirent la numéro 8
l'année dernière nous avons saisi
concernant le début de la production en
gaz mais nous n'avons pas reçu la
réponse écrite le ministère de l'énergie
et a promis de répondre mais il n'y a
pas eu de réponse le bois coûte très
chère vallée ballon de gaz ont été
interdits comment vivre que faire je
soixante dix ans mon mari est 74 ans
même si près de nous il y a des datchas
des résidents secondaires qui ont du gaz
mais qui appartiennent au maire et ils
vivent très bien comment peut-on vivre
ce tu n'as donc c'est la région de
catherine bourgain si je comprends
qu'elle le gaz chez la datcha du maire
ça veut dire que le tuyau de gaz doit
circuler pas très loin et donc
conformément à la décision qui a été
prise
votre terrain doit pouvoir être
gratuitement équipe et en gaz en ce qui
concerne les actions à suivre ici c'est
encore un sujet à part et qui est lié au
fait qu' il faut améliorer cette
conduire cette gratification jusqu'à
votre terrain dont vous avez les données
de cette personne oui nous avons tous
les ânes et attendez attendez laissez
moi ses coordonnées pour que je les ai
et nous allons faire en sorte que
effectivement ce qui a été promis
c'est à dire que la personne soit
brancher gratuitement et ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur on va sans la karatchaïevo
tcherkessie ya sept ans direct allez-y
bonjour bonjour rosa je m'adresse à vous
au nom des habitants de la partie nord
de la ville aux jeux gotha de la
république karatchaïevo tcherkessie je
vous demande de nous aider nous avons un
problème de gazéification de
l'approvisionnement agace le tuyau est à
200 mètres de nous mais selon nos
calculs ces deux cent mille roubles pour
une famille sera coté ainsi nous avons
nous sommes principalement des jeunes
familles nombreuses et c'est énorme pour
nos familles
je vous demande de nous aider à nous
connecter au gaz parce que nos autorités
locales nous disent qu'ils n'ont pas de
moyens
nous n'habitons pas dans les montagnes
et les gazoducs et tout près
pourriez-vous le contrôler s'il vous
plaît sens et une liaison directe l'aca
heureuse a dit moi c'est 200 milles
route dont on vous parle c'est c'est de
l'argent qu'on vous demande pour que les
conduites de gaz ait jusqu'à chez vous
non ce sont toutes nos dépenses cumulées
par mois c'est la partie de ce qui reste
de préciser bien c'est quoi ce dépenses
c'est à dire c'est que le tuyau h chez
vous et qu'ils soient aménagés autour de
votre logement
c'est l'autorisation de construction
d'abord c'est l'autorisation exigent de
l'argent pour cela
ensuite pour conduire le tuyau sur la
distance
c'est à peu près 200 mille roubles
c'est à dire jusqu'à votre logement
c'est ça c'est à dire que la conduite
est juste mais oui mais pas seulement
jusqu'à ma maison il y a des gens qui
habitent plus plus loin cette je
comprends région est partiellement ghazi
fier et beaucoup de personnes mangent
mal de gaz
regardez rosa je vais m'intéresser à
cette question je vais parler avec le
dirigeant de votre république
ce que je sais que vous sachiez que les
autres citoyens le sachent c'est que il
y a les conduites de gaz principal
à partir de ces conduites les connexions
jusqu'aux logements doivent se faire
gratuitement
ils doivent le faire mme soit c'est aux
frais de gazprom soit c'est aux frais de
l'organisation des entreprises
responsables de la gazéification
l'expression c'est d'aller jusque
jusqu'à votre palissade c'est
l'expression qu'on utilise après à
l'intérieur de votre terrain proprement
dit et encore j'en ai parlé il ya
quelques jours avec les responsables du
gouvernement c'est à dire que pour qu'il
y ait un contrat unique pour tout le
monde c'est à dire que l'aménagement au
niveau de votre logement de votre
terrain ça ça doit se faire de façon
centralisée à des prix à des tarifs
préférentiels et que ce soit le même
schéma pour tout le monde ce que je veux
dire c'est que la conduite de gaz
jusqu'à votre palissade ça ça doit être
gratuitement c'est pas 2 200 mille trois
cent mille ou cent mille roubles 11
millions de roubles
cela ne vous regarde pas je vous assure
que je veux en parler avec le dirigeant
de la république
nous allons parler de ça concrètement
merci beaucoup est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de la réponse que je vais
apporter
oui mais notre région est tout neuf et
alors il n'ya beaucoup de choses qui est
à faire mais ça c'est une autre question
pour le gaz oui si ce sera ainsi nous
serons reconnaissance reconnaissant la
cour je vais contrôler cette question je
vous remercie
des questions de la vie quotidienne ce
questions sur les questions du projet
vous permettez je vais expliquer une
fois que la loi sur
gratuit a commencé à fonctionner le co2
du piquage des tuyaux a augmenté de 2 ou
3 fois c'est pas que la loi commencé à
être aidé entre en vigueur
la question c'est pas la distance en
kilomètres de plus ou moins c'est que
avec l'augmentation des tarifs sur
certains types de production et
notamment sur métal justement tisseyre
ou conduites de gaz
là il ya différents intermédiaires qui
interviennent et qui ajoute l'ong
pourcentage sur ces travaux et c'est
pour ça que je dis il faut qu'on examine
la possibilité de faire un contrat
unique pour tout le monde à un tarif
préfère si le coût du projet a augmenté
c'est l'effet papillon devenu plus c'est
la question sur laquelle nous devons
être particulièrement important et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ceux qui
en parlent et je répète encore une fois
c'est pour cela que actuellement le
gouvernement travaillent à élaborer un
schéma type 1 contre la loi sur race ce
mille gratuit du gaz de gaz non pas ne
concerne pas des petits mobiliers
de la région par exemple rayton le cela
coûte 90 mille roubles volgograd un
gazoduc et privés à 15 mètres le
propriétaire exige trois cent mille
roubles pour approvisionner en gaz
aidez nous à 600 nous y retrouver sur
les petites entreprises de jardinage
l'horticulture
il faut voir où les gens habitent donc
il ya beaucoup de ce sont des milliers
deux localités de ce type dans les rues
sic donc la première étape c'est de
faire en sorte que ce dernier kilomètre
soit assurée gratuitement c'était là la
région de moscou il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vivent dans ces chartes sillage
c'est le cas de beaucoup qui vivent
comme ça mais la question de résidence
permanente où les gens vivent
concrètement c'est à dire les localités
là où les gens habitent c'est ça c'est
la première étape
donc il ya différents types
d'horticulture de jardinage donc c'est à
dire qu' il ya des associations des
collectivités qui se crée autour de ça
il y à des entreprise de jardinage qui
se trouve au sein des localités c'est à
dire que au sein de cette localité
donc il faut ici gratuitement que la
connexion aux réseaux gaziers soit faite
ici jusqu'à ce terrain donc il ya des
milliers de localités qui sont concernés
par ce cette première étape de
gazéification ensuite les autres schémas
de d'associations de jardinage doivent
pouvoir aussi bénéficier d'ici 2024 2025
doivent bénéficier de ces mesures
donc c'est le programme de gazéification
du produit cela concerne soixante dix
sept entités territoriales de la
fédération de russie pourquoi pas tout
parce que certains jeux non
tout simplement pas de système de
classification centralisée ça c'est le
cas donc dans ce cas il y à des
programmes de qualification spécifique
mais nous allons voir comment nous
allons mener cette première étape vous
voyez que déjà ici il ya pas mal de
questions qui se posent ici toujours
autour du dernier kilomètre jusqu'au
logement où habitent les gens encore une
fois c'est la première étape avait
laissé ça concerne des dizaines de
milliers
deux localités et donc il faut continuer
on ne crie on conçoit des messages des
personnes de tout âge de tout l'ensemble
de pays pour les jeunes beaucoup de
questions sont liées à l'internet
nous avons un sujet sur la régulation de
l'internet
je vous propose de donner la parole à
moscow c'est un appel direct
vous êtes en direct je vous écoute
monsieur poutine bonjour aujourd'hui
kita je suis blogueur je m'appelle
intelligence qui j'ai plus d'un million
de followers sur instagram et nous avons
mes collègues ont déjà clarifié ce sujet
en 2010 us 2018 mais c'est un sujet
tellement actuelle que je ne peux pas
l'oublier
je vais donc profiter de l'opportunité
est ce que nous devons nos atteindre au
blocage des réseaux sociaux des sites et
des hausses timides you étrangers comme
tik tok télégramme twitter youtube
non nous n'avons pas cette intention on
ne va bloquer personnes on va travailler
ensemble avec ma il ya des problèmes
c'est à dire que il est ne remplissent
pas nos exigences et les lois russes
nikita vos sept citoyens russes et et
vous savez votre dignité patriotique et
vos collègues également et quand on nous
dit on va travailler chez vous mais si
cela quelque chose ne vous plaît pas
alors gare à vous écouter
cela nous humilient si il travaille sur
notre territoire et s'ils gagnent de
l'argent ils doivent respecter nos lois
rien de plus cela dit à la première
étape et j'espère que
nous allons nous limiter par cette
première étape nous exigeons que c'est
plate forme internationale ouvre sur
notre territoire leur représentation des
personnes morales avec lesquels on
pourrait dire ok on on leur dit vous
diffuser une pornographie aux biens des
informations sur le suicide
vous devez le supprimer eh ben ils ne
nous écoutent pas ce n'est pas correct
pas un seul pays qui se respecte ne
réagit pas d'une autre façon il faut
être civilisé parce que même dans leur
propre pays
ce n'est pas trop trop civilisés de leur
part mais nous espérons qu'on nous
écoute et certains collègues vont ouvrir
leurs représentations sur un autre
territoire
sinon s'il ne respecte pas la loi russe
il y a des moyens techniques de
ralentissement de la rapidité de
connexion et j'en passe mais de toute
façon je répète nous n'avons pas
l'intention de fermer quelqu'un mais
qu'est ce que je voudrais voir pour que
nos structures heureuse se développe
dans cette direction et offre une
possibilité à des personnes comme vous
un des blogueurs les opportunités de
travailler dans les réseaux sociaux
russes aient utilisé des plateformes
russe de réaliser votre talent et offrir
des services à nos citoyens et rendre
notre vie meilleure merci beaucoup
d'utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux on
était soulagé maintenant y compris
nikita surtout ceux qui ont un million
d'abonnés comme parce que il faut se
mettre d'accord et par interdire comme
c'était le cas de télégrammes à mon avis
avec des g tout est réglé cela
fonctionne le centre du traitement des
messages des siennes et rémy sauveur
c'est à vous mais la merci beaucoup
maintenant passer du sujet de tik tok et
d'instagram un sujet plus actuelle les
services communaux l'asie mais vladimir
huit jeux
vous montrez les surveiller syfy cas de
pma que les habitants de la localité 10
me en cas nous ont envoyé l'appartement
soixante dix mètres carrés et l'a reçu
vous voyez 74000 780 mille roubles
l'appartement voisin de 60 m² la somme
pour avril 50 1661 roubles nous avons
des documents nous n'inventons rien
c'est la vérité nous allons essayer de
contacter les habitants de 10 me à neuf
cas qui nous ont envoyé ces documents il
devrait avoir un appel direct avec nous
donc les services communaux 10 me au cas
où je vois
bonjour vous êtes en direct vous parler
au président salesi bonjour vladimir
vladimirovitch orlen je m'appelle alter
l'aise derrière moi sont les habitants
de la localité dit me anne k nous vivons
rue pnr 5
nous avons tous été transférés des
habitations vétustes dans le contexte du
programme spécial nous avons été très
heureux mais plusieurs faits nohant
affligé d'abord la somme des paiements a
dit supplémentaire va jusqu'à 330 mille
roubles ce qui contredit et la
législation nous avons racheté nos
appartements
nous avons déménagé en février cette
année et au mois d'avril et nous avons
déjà reçu les documents les factures de
40 à 80 mille roubles
nous avons saisi toutes les instances
possibles possible réponse était la même
que c'était des tarifs économiquement
raisonnable
nous n'arrivons pas à régler la
situation nous avons saisi le parquet
l'administration du gouverneur
l'administration de la région toutes les
instances possibles
l'inspection des logements
donc concernant cette politique des prix
mais 70% de notre maison
ce sens et on vous écoute vous pouvez
continuer donc soixante dix pour cent
des habitats de notre maison ce sont des
retraités leurs pensions des retraités
se dit vingt mille roubles alors que les
services communaux
c'est donc de 20 mille roubles et même
plus ce sont des prix yriel irréalisable
donc les gens sont obligés de survivre
il n'y a pas des prix de ce genre à vos
écoutes il ya quelqu'un qui l'appelle
apparemment tous ses amis ont vu sur en
direct peut-être ayons décidé de
l'appliquer donc pour un pour l'eau
froide et ses 333 rouble et le
coefficient tri le triplé quoi qui tient
ici quand on vivait dans la maison
précédente c'était 1480 de roubles pour
le réchauffement
maintenant c'est 5331 roubles écouter
talent j'ai bien compris votre question
je sais pas très bien entendu vous avez
dit que lors du débat de management vous
avez dû payer une somme modique
oui si vous permettez je peux formuler
de manière plus précise en septembre de
l'année dernière nous avons été invités
dans l'administration pour signer
l'application pour le déménagement et en
même temps nous avons écrit cette
application nous avons confirmé notre
accord
mais déjà quelqu'un d' a écrit pour nous
les applications et donc là c'était dit
ah si je vous demande de me prendre
l'ancien appartement et de me donner en
nouveau compte tenu du prix du rachat ce
qu'ils disent est ce qui est impliqué
déjà des paiements supplémentaires
les résidents ont refusé de signer mais
une semaine plus tard on nous a réuni
encore une fois dans l'administration et
donc ils nous ont assuré qu'il n'y
aurait pas de paiement supplémentaire
que c'était sur cette susceptibles
d'avoir des poursuites et que cela ne se
ferait jamais les gens lui en crue et
ont signé ces applications est de toute
évidence cette année nous avons tous
reçu sept ses factures pour pour les
paiements ou les coefficients tard
l'année j'ai vu le jeune femme a
derrière vous c'est un groupe de soutien
puis la victoire sera anneaux
aucun doute je n'ai pas compris
de quelle somme complémentaire à payer
il s'agit on va voir tout ça les
chiffres que vous mentionnez écouter vos
montant des je pense qu'ils nous entend
par la télé mais j'espère que vos
montante et je ne comprends pas de
quelle somme s'agit-il et pour quelles
raisons les chiffres que vous mentionnez
c'est scandaleux
le paiement pour le ravitaillement en
eau en électricité
l'oci je ne je ne me trompe pas compte
37 troubles pour pour mètres cubes de
roubles pour jets calories mais je ne
peux pas comprendre d'où viennent ces
chiffres
oui je comprend peut-être la maison et
n'avait pas une totalité de locataires
et dans ce cas les locataires qui ont
occupé les appartements ont dû payer
pour le reste mais
si je comprends bien ce n'est pas votre
cas mais je vous promets qu'on va voir
tout ça et on va élucider cette
situation vous savez en effet je vous
comprends à maintes reprises je visitais
des logements vétustes et les gens sont
très heureux quand on leur propose de
déménager dans une dans un appartement
assez confortable mais cela doit être
accompagnée par des mesures de soutien
et j'espère que ça sera aussi votre cas
vous avez toutes les coordonnées
oui nous avons des données s'est il
s'agit de 2004 dans la région de tioumen
gears of arland takero beach on va
élucider cette situation propose de voir
à quel d'autres problèmes existent dans
le dos les services communaux je vous
propose de voir une vidéo
depuis ce cover le programme municipal
de la ville a été mise en oeuvre en 2015
pour l'approvisionnement en eau chaude
ce lavage se fait tous les trois mois
c'est ce processus se fait tous les 3
mois ce nettoyage se fait pour moi et
c'est tout va dans les tuyaux de la
ville
la circulation de l'eau s'arrête dans
les nouvelles maisons
les autorités municipales n'ont pas
voulu résoudre ces questions là il
s'agit en effet est-ce que andrei
maintenant parler oui peut-être plus
tard si chers collègues essayé de
contacter pasqua fait pour l'instant je
peux poser une autre question pourquoi
seulement dans l'est du pays il ya un
vice premier ministre allemand on va
revenir à ce problème d'accord
concernant le vice premier ministre qui
est chargé de certaines régions
nous avons cette expérience en effet et
concernant la région de l'extrême orient
et la région arctique la région fédérale
sud
on en a parlé avec le gouvernement cette
expérience s'est révélée positive et
nous nous sommes entendus que le premier
ministre va avancer des propositions qui
vont concerner d'autres régions
à mon avis c'est assez raisonnable
puisque le contact avec les régions
cette immersion dans les problèmes de la
région cela donne des résultats et ce
contact permanent est très utile et
j'espère que la décision qui est prise
au centre devrait
être plus efficaces donc les vice
premiers ministres vont répondre des
autres je mens pas d'autres régions mais
de la région concrètes
donc chacun jouera son c'est ça notre
décision
on va voir comment ce système va
fonctionner en général non pas en
extrême-orient uniquement en extrême
orient aux biens dans le sud est
cherchons de contacter puisque avait
pour l'instant nous passons dans le
centre du traitement je n'aime je vous
demande des siennes à rémy zoo va merci
beaucoup
quelques mots seulement sur ce que nous
voulons terre ont fait pendant le
fonctionnement du direct de la ligne
directive ont aidé à envoyer des
médicaments et des produits
ils ont aidé à acheter un fauteuil
roulant électrique
ils ont même fait tomber un arbre qui
l'unissait la vie des gens de la région
de pskov qu'est ce que nous avons vu vu
une fois que la personne se plaint de
quelque chose des fonctionnaires
l'apprennent et commence à lui appelé
mais voir le menacer notre volontaire et
li na a connu une histoire règles comme
ça nous avons reçu un message de la
présidente de la ville de continuer ce
que
il n 1 qu'elle unit l'homme dans son
message elle a demandé de l'aider pour
réparer le toit d'un jardin d'enfants
235 ou son petit et fils allait régler
ma c'était une
en marque de sanitaires des questions
conditions sanitaires complète
nous avons des photos de ce jardin
d'enfants j'ai appelé le département de
l'éducation ai je demandé de donner des
commentaires là dessus mais ils n'ont
pas cru que c'était ce qu'il s'agissait
d'un volontaire de laly direct ils ont
refusé de me donner des informations et
lendemain il énerve la dîme et rona a
appelé encore une fois et a demandé de
supprimer son message passe parce que
les représentants du département de
l'enseignement l'ont contacté et on
demandait de supprimer sa demande en
disant que qu'elle devait réfléchir à
l'avenir de son petit fils et oui c'est
une sorte de formule assez
qui n'est pas créée clair et donc on va
contacter et on peut le faire
nova partir on va aller dans le parti
oui où elle est en direct
elena kalina vous êtes en direct
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur de
parler directement
après tout ce que vous avez entendu
bonjour je vous entends très mal je
n'entend presque pas ce que vous dites
allez-y on vous entend il n' a pas
relève nous de votre histoire
voici la rejoint par téléphone où on va
essayer de l'appeler appelez là
maintenant tout de suite sur son
téléphone
surtout qu'elle est a donné le la les
fans nous allons essayer de vous joindre
par téléphone
c'est comme s'il y avait des jeunes eu
des tempêtes magnétiques des problèmes
techniques mais même vous pouvez
l'appeler au téléphone tout simplement
sa collègue s contact
elena vladimir osnachs oui on nous
sommes entrain de quelle prenne
son téléphone mais maintenant nous
venons de recevoir l'appel de pskov bien
elena on revient on revient vers beau
prince haïti lorsque les nazis mais on
ne nous entend matin oui mais maintenant
je vous entends très très mal bonjour à
l'entrée nous avons regardé votre vidéo
vous avez un proche très créatif la
question parlez nous de vos problèmes
bonjour chers membres du studio et
monsieur poutine
c'est vrai que le problème est hors
commun parce que le programme eau propre
qui a été effectué en 2015 apps cover
est censé nous fournir une source d'eau
d'eau et donc la ville depuis ce qu'on
va trouver à une source alternative des
eaux souterraines dans puis de la
profondeur de 10 m mais pendant la mise
en oeuvre de ce projet personne n'a
prêté attention à l'eau chaude et à ce
qu'elle devenait canton la
roche-aux-fées l'eau qui vient de ces
sources souterraines est très bonne en
terme en bactériologique
donc il n'ya pas de bactéries et les
traits propres elle correspond à tout
les exigences sanitaires mais une fois
qu'elle est chauffé il y à ces résidus
qui apparaissent nous avons une maison
de trois ans qui a des problèmes avec
chaude
la preuve il y à des tueurs de propylène
pour le propylène il ne peut pas y avoir
de youyous
donc il peut pas être rouillé mais on
voit que en bas de ce tueur il y à ces
résidus donc nous sommes obligés de
nettoyer constamment les tuyaux est donc
officiellement toutes les normes sont
respectées
mais le gouverneur de de la région
participent matin la régulation de ce
problème il faut toujours laisser site
cette institution trouver des
financements mais personne n'offre ses
financements
donc on cherche des moyens pour créer
cette station de traitement de l'eau
donc nous vous demandons de l'aide
malheureusement la qualité du réseau et
ma mauvaise le problème
andrei est compris je ne pensais pas un
système ancien un système assez nouveau
ressens c'est à dire que
j'ai comme bien compris bien évidemment
cela nécessite un peu plus de ressources
pour être résolu très prochainement pour
ce type de problème nous allons accorder
un certain nombre de fonds pour des pour
des projets infrastructurels et ses 500
milliards de roubles 250 milliards de
roubles iront pour le fond de bien-être
de la population
et encore il leur a des des
améliorations sur le sur l'aide de la
population et je dirais que toutes ces
ressources qui ont été particulièrement
parce partiellement dépenser mais je
sais qu'il ya des questions parce que
les méchants sont pas toujours satisfait
des conditions dans lesquelles ils sont
aujourd'hui et je donnerai des
instructions au gouvernement ministère
du les travaux publics et aux services
communaux pour que notamment le ministre
ousmane la route nous l'ennemi est aussi
le gouverneur le gouverneur pour qu'ils
réfléchissent à des solutions et à des
sources de financement pour résoudre la
question que vous avez posé une toute
petite qui sont malheureusement on
entend très très mal alors que jelena
kalina nous avons le contact sonore avec
elle nous l'avons contacté qu'elena
callinan ce que vous nous entendez et
pourquoi continuer le sujet de l'eau
sale quand nous avons étudié
une question à ce qu est la région de
penza il y avait de l'eau très sale qui
coulé des robinets
on ne peut pas se laver même sans parler
de nous a envoyé des photos aussi dans
la région de saint pétersbourg le manque
d'eau tournon est très sale on est
obligé d'acheter de l'eau d'un lac j'ai
déjà parlé et je le répète encore c'est
tous ces problèmes de de ce type
donc nous allons pris la décision
d'affecter des ressources
supplémentaires pour résoudre ces
questions qu'est ce qui se passe ici
tout le monde le sait je l' ai déjà dit
les autorités régionales municipales et
c'est de ne pas prendre de décisions
entraînant une augmentation des tarifs
parce que là le niveau de ressources de
la population est trop limité pour que
les gens puissent assumer de telles
dépenses donc ça on comprend bien donc
évidemment les autorités locales
s'abstiennent de prendre des mesures
dans ce domaine donc il n'ya pas
toujours de remplacement des tuyauteries
tel que prévu donc c'est un processus
complexe et un manque d'attractivité ici
pour les solutions qui sont proposées
donc au niveau des services locatifs
donc je vous ai dit on à 150 milliards
de dollars qe2 de routes qui sont
attribuées au fonds de bien-être de la
population
tout cela ce sont des des sources
budgétaires qui sont définies et nous
allons continuer à travailler sur ces
questions
donc au niveau des régions un certain
nombre de propositions vont être
formulée je demande aux gouvernements
locaux de proposer va revenir au centre
du traitement des messages
nous avons beaucoup de messages très
intéressant concernant les
l'état vétusté des écoles je vous
propose d'aller en extrême à rien au
rien et d'avoir une en appel vidéo de
hausse l'isq vous êtes en direct
présentez vous bonjour bonjour ne tolère
c'est la ville la localité basque jon k
monsieur poutine nous avons froid
nous sommes très inquiet excusez moi je
veux lire ça sur un peu fou de joie bien
parce que je suis très stressée la fin
de l'année scolaire
la dernière année scolaire rencontre dès
dans notre école dans le vieux bâtiment
il y a eu un écroulement d'un mur s ce
bâtiment a plus de 50 ans nous avons un
autre bâtiment mais il ya très peu de
place là-dedans et donc les conditions
ne sont pas propices nous allons voir de
près de nous à construire une nouvelle
école moderne il faut à l'armée nous a
quitté notre ville en 2009 et depuis la
ville
et en détresse l'eau est sale et les
maisons sont dans un tel état proche d'
incendies et donc les routes c'est une
histoire à part comme dans l'ensemble du
pays
il n'y a pas de moyens d'assainissement
nous avons des eaux usées qui coule
justement près de la ville d'och est le
cours des monnaies attention s'il vous
plaît à l'intérieur si je comprends bien
le problème les problèmes sont nombreux
et je vais évidemment en parler avec des
autorités régionales pour que voir les
solutions qui peuvent être proposées ici
et aussi au niveau du ministère de la
défense voir ce qu'il peut faire je
comprends que ce qui vous préoccupe
c'est en priorité c'est l'état de
l'école oui je vois que c'est la
question principale est joie que les
enfants sont avec vous c'est l'école
derrière vous si un mur une cloison est
tombé je comprends qu'effectivement on
est dans un état de désuétude
donc on a ici 440000 des écoles en
russie est certain nombre d'entre elles
sont dans un état plus que critique
alors la question ce n'est pas de les
remettre en état ça veut dire qu'il faut
construire de nouvelles écoles et c'est
en en gros 1300 écoles qui doivent être
construites encore dans le pays dont ça
concerne effectivement la vôtre et ils
font construire une nouvelle je
comprends et 60%
des écoles ont besoin de travaux courant
sur les quarante mille et 10% sont dans
un état vraiment critique
donc il est là encore il ya des fonds
budgétaires qui ont été alloués à ce
programme de rénovation mais encore je
vais encore une fois je vais discuter
avec les autorités régionales pour
qu'elles s'occupent en priorité de votre
héros
je vous souhaite tout le meilleur et
saluer les enfants pour moi elena kalina
et indirects avec nous il n' a pourtant
tenté vous nous entendez qu'est-ce qu'il
ya ça ne marche pas par mons et vos
autorités qui veulent pas qu'on vous
entende a maintenant ils ne veulent pas
aller je vous entends bien bonjour
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire notre
jardin d'enfants c'est l'école jardin
d'enfants pour des enfants qui ont des
problèmes de santé il existe depuis 1981
2 donc ces quarante ans qu'il existe
déjà et ils ne veulent rien faire nous
avions un groupe d'expérience donc mon
petit fils il le fréquente il a eu deux
pendant deux années il regardait donc le
toit a commencé à couler nous avons
saisi plusieurs institutions en
suppliant de nous aider nous avons reçu
des promesses mais avant que je ne je
n'écrive
un message pour vous rien n'a marché
mais l'histoire éclaire use moins clair
ilana vous nous entendez je pense qu'il
pourra nous voir aussi la diffusion
chers collègues qu est-ce qu on peut
contacter encore une fois à bord que le
président cuisse est en tout cas pour
l'école j'ai construit le projet mais
quand je dis écoles jeudi aussi les
écoles maternelles c'est tous ensemble
comment pouvez-vous commenter la
sitution donc en tout cas la question
oui on l'a menacé mais qui si j'ai bien
compris il est la direction de ce jardin
d'enfants c'est la région de kemerovo
nouveau coup aux notes la menacer de le
priver de la tutelle de la petite fille
à sa petite fille parce que la
grand-mère vais adresser une requête en
tout cas lna ne vous inquiétez pas si
vous nous écoutez
à propos de votre petite fille
considérer que ce problème n'existe pas
ceux qui vous menacent ce sont eux qui
auront des problèmes en ce qui concerne
l'école j'avais répondu justement vous à
d'autres questions sur des problèmes
similaires je dis qu'il ya un certain
nombre de fonds budgétaires qui sont
attribués aux rénovations rénovation
complète ou partielle d'établissements
scolaires nous avons les coordonnées
je vais discuter avec le gouverneur donc
la région de kemerovo donc monsieur le
gouverneur je vous prie de traiter les
demandes des requêtes des citoyens qui
sont adressés en l'occurrence c'est
important d'en l'occurrence il s'agit
ici d'une école qui comprend une école
une section maternelle donc les
responsables qui cherchent à effrayer
intimider les citoyens je veux que cette
question sera résolue que vous allez
prendre les mesures nécessaires
j'attends votre compte rendu chers
collègues nous passons aux allant de
nouveau dans le centre de traitement des
messages at a les yeux rivés nous avons
aussi des exemples d'idées des problèmes
qui ont été reçus le même avant le début
de la ligne directe lé cas alieva de
maykop nous a contacté et je sais que
les volontaires ont réussi à l'aider
c'est céline hamida qui a contacté la
jeune fille et sa mère qu'est ce que
vous avez réussi à faire jeu poutine
malika 3 13 ans il a perdu la vue à 6 1
nous avons été tellement touché par son
histoire que nous avons saisi le franc
de peuples nationale et les militants de
ce mouvement ont trouvé un moyen de lui
acheter le dit ce pays frère et la
question de malika et et s'il était
possible d'inclure des c
moyens techniques avancées dans la liste
des moyens qui sont donnés gratuitement
nous avons une liste qui est approuvé
par le gouvernement et le ministère de
la santé publique des outils de
réhabilitation pour les gens qui ont des
problèmes avec la santé et en plus nous
avons réalisé nous réalisons
actuellement des projets de messages
électroniques pour que les gens puissent
choisir de façon autonome
un outil médical pour la réhabilitation
mais aussi d'être remboursés par la
trésorerie
oui c'est faisable on va le faire
je crois que les ministres ne
s'entendent en particulier le ministre
de la santé publique
je propose d'inclure dans cette liste
cet outil brel pour continuer avec notre
écran ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu
un grand sujet la politique sociale le
marché de travail
on peut donner la parole
la localité a bâti ce que c'est une bio
bonjour monsieur poutine à bonjour
j'habite dans la localité a basculé
région de tioumen ces deux là lâche trac
on va j'ai 20 ans j'ai 51 ans
ça fait quatre ans que je n'arrive pas à
me trouver un travail
g6 et le gouverneur toutes les
institutions mais personne ne peut
résoudre la solution quand en russie il
y aura des places de travail pour tout
le monde pour les jeunes et pour les
gens de notre âge
tout le monde est fatigué de ce genre de
problème de manque d'emplois oui cette
lan a bien sûr la question du marché de
travail la question d'emploi c'est une
question de principe
si vous avez du travail vous êtes donc
membres de sociétés qui est très demandé
vous êtes indépendante et c'est un volet
très important pour le travail de l'état
d administration sur place à tous les
niveaux la région de tioumen c'est une
des régions bien de l'eau pde part des
revenus les rythmes de développement et
l'administration de la région de tioumen
devrait porter plus d'attention sur les
problèmes dont vous parlez
malheureusement durant la pandémie
nous avons constaté la hausse du chômage
avant c'était 4,7 pour cent
malheureusement cet indice constitue
environ 5 2 9%
il ya une certaine baisse quand même
mais le gouvernement a une grande
mission d'atteindre le taux de chômage
d'avant la crise et avant la pandémie à
savoir à 95 7 %
c'est tendance persiste et il faut la
maintenir en employant tous les moyens
mais il faut développer l'économie pour
ça pour que les gens obtiennent le
salaire décent et si vous ne parvenez
pas à trouver du travail
c'est très malheureux ce n'est pas lié
au problème de la pandémie directement
et bien sûr la région de tioumen possède
d un grand budget quand même des indices
économiques qui sont assez bien devrait
porter l'attention sur ce problème je
crois que le gouvernement nous entende
et j'espère qu'il va porter l'attention
sur la commune où vous habitez petit
monsieur jerc ce n'est pas pour rien que
les nac ligne à des problèmes de réseau
parce que il y à une tentative d'
attaque sur par des acquiert parce que
c'est là que le système non je sais sur
ie et hackers russes nous regardons nous
revient on passe à la culture qui est
normal et privés d'attention et mais
celle que or ici je suis professeur de
littérature je travaille dans une petite
localité
nous ne sommes pas riches mais élèves
peuvent aller dans un centre de région
mais ils n'ont pas d'argent pour aller
au théâtre musée aux expositions ce
qu'on peut inventer quelque chose pour
aider les des collines et ce il ne s'est
pas présenté il a juste envoyé un
message
l'institutrice où il est institutrice de
littérature nous avons des propositions
à ce sujet depuis des mois nous en
parlons avec le gouvernement ce sera un
outil intitulé une carte pouchkine
il s'agit de la possibilité
et des moyens financiers assez modeste
mais quand même est considérable pour
pallier à ce problème
il s'agit des jeunes de 14 à 22 ans qui
peuvent en profiter
de septembre à décembre de l'année en
cours et l'année prochaine également
donc cette catégorie de jeunes
pourraient bénéficier de cette carte
boussekine ils auront à ce compte 3000
euros le pot 4 en trois mille roubles si
ils veulent visiter le bolchoï ils
peuvent le faire mais là les billets
sont très cher quand même ça sera une
seule fois mais de toute façon ils
auront la possibilité de d'aller au
concert dans les musées les expositions
c'est à dire visiter les événements
culturels et nous espérons que les
jeunes vont bénéficier de cette nouvelle
possibilité et pourrez visiter non
seulement les événements culturels sur
place mais aussi à haut niveau culturel
oui écoutez je crois que c'est très
important pour les jeunes faut trouver
un moyen essentiel et loisirs mais il
faut s'initier à notre patrimoine
culturel et ils sont obligés à
économiser beaucoup de choses mais
j'espère qu'ils n'auront pas la
possibilité d'économiser et le faire va
au frais de l'état suppose il monte un
peu passé à la politique antérieure
sujet autorités fédérales si vous voulez
j'espère que rien ne nous empêchera de
lancer cet appel
l'appel depuis krasnodar jose en prie
monsieur poutine
vous avez accédé au pouvoir par la
transition volontaire par monsieur
eltsine est ce qu une telle transition
de pouvoir est possible de nos jours ce
qu'il ya dans votre équipe il ya une
personne à qui vous pourrez transférer
le pouvoir sans aucun doute
mikolaj écouter boris eltsine n'a pas
transféré son pouvoir à moi non
conformément à notre loi est la loi
fondamentale constitue la constitution
le président du gouvernement devient le
président par intérim ici et l'ancien
président à part de sa fonction à il ya
eu toutes sortes d'événements qui ont
précédé je dirigeais le service fédéral
de sécurité
et quand monsieur eltsine m'a proposé
d'occuper la fonction de secrétaire du
conseil de sécurité
c'est une structure sous l'égide du
président g j'ai dû choisir une personne
qui va occuper le service cette fonction
mais les personnes auxquelles j'ai
proposé cette fonction ont refusé et
j'étais surpris pourquoi parce que la
situation était difficile dans le pays
et elle n'est à peu prêt à assumer cette
responsabilité
en plus c'est quand boris eltsine m'a
proposé de porter ma candidature j'ai du
g10 écoutez je ne crois pas que je suis
prêt et il m'a dit on va y revenir
réfléchissez donc et finalement en effet
boris il est parti je suis devenu
président par intérim mais la décision
sur celui qui va présider la fédération
de russie revient au citoyen de la
fédération de russie c'est leur droit
ils choisissent le président par le vote
direct et secret et c'est la seule voie
qui est possible
concernant les personnes qui pourraient
être président de la russie
d'un côté lui on peut toujours trouver
une personne mais de l'autre côté
ma responsabilité est grande et elle
résume dans le fait pour pour conseiller
aux personnes qui vont porter leur
candidature à la présidence et c'est
comme ça que ce comment ça se passe dans
d'autres pays
je ne connais pas d'exception et le
temps viendra
et j'espère que je pourrai dire que
cette personne là à mon avis est digne
d'être président de la fédération de
russie
ce magnifique pays notre patrie la
russie chers collègues nous passons la
parole au centre de traitement des
messages
nous savons que vous vous êtes au corps
au centre de cette ligne directe
merci nous avons une question qui porte
sur la politique extérieure par
intérieur je vous propose de regarder la
vidéo faite par andré jérémy sauf de
saint pétersbourg
peut-être ils nous ont pas entendus mais
ce putin bonjour je m'appelle ans et
venait de vous réunir avec monsieur
byden président américain les médias
nous ont informés que la réunion s'est
déroulée dans une atmosphère
constructive de tout de suite
la russie a commencé à recevoir les
menaces de sanctions et de restrictions
pour le patient alma ou pour n'importe
quoi pour se justifier on dit que peu de
choses des bandes de baden qu'il ne
décide pas vraiment de rien et à quoi ça
sert donc de rencontrer le président
belledonne cyr peu de choses dépendent
de lui
merci nicolas y entrer par dont il ya
beaucoup de choses qui dépendent du
président américain
oui ils ont leur propre système
politique
il ya toutes sortes de frein et
contrepoids mais vaut porter votre
attention sur le fait et qui est très
important c'est une question importante
à mon avis il faut le voir que notre
façon est ce que quelque chose dépend du
président américain ou pas une autre
question se pose en famille vous avez
par exemple des enfants des petits
enfants et il ya un petit un petit
enfant qui a fait quelque chose et sa
maman lui dit réfléchit bien ne fait pas
comme ça et il fait comme ça alors il a
branché quelque chose dans sa tête ait
quelque chose à fonctionner les mères et
les pères qu'on fonctionnel virtuel aux
états unis des chercheurs des praticiens
donne des recommandations à leurs
dirigeants politiques alors classe
politique au pouvoir dans un sens large
quelles sont ses conseils qu'il disait
écouter l'époque où on est y est on
dominer le monde
après l'écroulement de l'union
soviétique la période du monde
unipolaire ça c'est révolu et donc il
faut partir du fait que le monde évolue
quelles que soient les sanctions
dirigées contre la russie et quelles que
soient les menaces
la russie se développe et la
souveraineté économique s'affermit c'est
notre défense et surpasse certains pays
même les états unis l'asie se développe
également écouter ci en 91
le pib de la chine constitue et 20% du
pib américain aujourd'hui selon les
données des médias américains 120 % cela
veut dire que la richesse cumulée de la
chine dépasse la richesse des états unis
les échanges commerciaux de la chine
avec l'europe dépasse les échanges
commerciaux de l'europe et des états
unis c'est à dire que le monde a changé
radicalement et mais nos partenaires
américains comprennent d'un côté et
cette évolution c'est pourquoi il ya la
rencontre à genève mais de l'autre côté
coûte que coûte il persiste à dominer
toujours le monde et il y a de ce fait
toutes sortes de menaces et cette
conduite et destructive avec toutes ces
exercices militaires les provocations
et les sanctions cela ne dépend pas de
nous cela dépend de deux de même et
j'espère que cette prise de conscience
du monde qui évolue est en ce moment au
toqué évolué il y aura la nouvelle prise
conscience de ses propres priorités de
ses propres intérêts
cela va amener vers la situation où là
le monde soit plus raisonnable plus
équilibrée et nos échanges avec les
états unis seront normalisées maintenant
est ce qu'il y aura une réponse nous
avons reçu en textures les mais ça les
etats-unis parlent des sanctions pour la
violation de l'île rouge la russie qui
ait les moyens de sanction at elle pour
l'agression de nos lignes rouges de la
par les états unis mais je suis clean de
la région de homs que ça intéresse c'est
pas simplement que nous avons adapté
notre économie à cette politique de
sanctions je dirais que je suis un
certain plan cela a même été bénéfique
sur le plan de ce qu'on appelle le la
substitution des importations mais je
dirais que ça servi de coup de pouce à
la production industrielle et c'est à
dire que réellement ça nous apportait
des bénéfices je parle pas seulement de
l'agriculture qui a atteint des
résultats qu'on ne pouvait même pas
imaginer mais il y avait d'autres mais
par exemple le système de payement mire
oui le système de paiement mire et
germaine le renforcement d'une manière
générale du système financier
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous fait peur avec
des en cherchant à agir sur nos
obligations etc
les sanctions mais il ya la dette
extérieure
général pas seulement de l'état mais
aussi la dette commerciale
tout cela a baissé donc il y a des
avantages positifs mais prendre des
mesures de rétorsion qui vont nous
porter dommage nous mêmes on va pas le
faire ça non par exemple les sanctions
sur les moteurs russes pour les fusées
et là et effectivement les le matériel
américain continue à utiliser les
moteurs russes ça fait des décennies
qu'on travaille comme ça et est ce qu'on
arrive ils n'ont par exemple boy mais je
sais pas à quel est le pourcentage
peut-être 50 % il ya 50% des avions
boeing qui sont fabriqués avec du titane
russe d'anzhi
ils franchissent certaines lignes rouges
nous aurons de toute façon des réponses
automatiques qui seront suffisamment
sensible pour je répète encore une fois
les relations vis-à-vis pas seulement de
nous mais aussi de dans sa forme de nos
partenaires sont jamais partenaires
traditionnels
est ce que ça leur plaît de parler
toujours bien google dont je suis pas
sûr sur place de steve et le sujet vous
avez parlé de l'économie on va parler de
l'économie on va voir
qu'est-ce qu'on nous parle des salaires
nous avons une vidéo de la région de
baikal avec plus le voir vous êtes en
direct
dimitri père filière bonjour monsieur le
président nous sommes les
sapeurs-pompiers du ministère de la
défense civile
dimitri est ce que vous pouvez couper la
télé malheureusement il y à des coupures
du son si vous avez une tilt et les
imposteures s'il vous plaît copé non
nous n'avons pas de poste de télé
continue et je vous en prie monsieur le
président à la demande du président
russe
mais malheureusement il ya des coupures
du son en imposant
demetri malheureusement on ne vous
entend pas mettez vous on vous entend
pas ce qu'on va rétablir le contact avec
dimitri turf iliev peut-être changer de
rythme peut-être changé et fort pas par
les femmes si on vous entend puis après
le sens disparaît nous allons peut-être
vous pouvez vous approchez peut-être
parler moins fort parler peut-être plus
lentement très bien monsieur le
président je vais essayer de nouveau
vous êtes en direct est ce que vous
entendez monsieur le président à la
demande du président russe
le 2 juillet 2009 dans toutes les
structures régionales y compris notre
département de ceux des pompiers et
sapeurs les salaires restent les mêmes
et on ne prend pas en compte les
conditions de notre travail
s'il vous plaît porter votre attention
sur les salaires très bas des sapeurs
pompiers qui ne dépendent pas des
conditions de notre travail qui est très
difficile
si je prends si je comprends que le
salaire reste alors niveau du salaire
minimum
attendez attendez on va essayer de voir
avec dimitri vous avez pas les deux
langues l'augmentation des salaires
oui alors j'ai une question à vous poser
à ce propos
votre organisme dépendant du ministère
des situations d'urgence ou c'est une
structure régionale
mais c'est le précédent c'est une
non ce n'est pas le ministre des
situations d'urgence
cet accord alors regardez comme nous
avons parlé vous m'entendez vous
monsieur le président on vous entend
très bien très bien
quand nous avons parlé et j'en ai parlé
l'année dernière où l'année précédente
sur la nécessité d'augmenter les
salaires pour les agents je parle pas
des officiers je parle des agents des
services de pompiers de sauveteurs du
ministère des situations d'urgence il y
avait seize mille et on est arrivé à
32000 voir ce 40 voire plus je sais
qu'il ya pas mal de problèmes parce que
il ya un problème de postes vacants et
en fait ce qu'ils trouvent ça se trouve
c'est que les ressources accordées on se
sent un peu diluée dans tout ça après il
ya la situation des services
d'intervention qui sont en région
arctique mais vous en ai parlé
vous êtes une structure régionale est
exactement cela signifie que au niveau
des régions et dans la majorité d'entre
elles quand nous avons commencé à
augmenter les salaires des agents du
ministère
les régions ont augmenté aussi les
salaires de leurs structures régionales
parce que sinon il y avait les cadres il
y avait une fuite de cadres de la région
taza et caldav d'accord je comprends que
tout cela varie aussi en fonction des
niveaux d'allocations budgétaires mais
je vais parler avec votre gouverneur
parce que premièrement pas parce que
votre travail est dur c'est un travail
qui est dur qui est pénible qui est
dangereux et il mérite donc un salaire
conséquent
et deuxièmement c'est la fuite du
personnel qui passe d'un service
régional au service
ministériel et notamment dans la
situation aujourd'hui nous avons beau
nous avons un certain nombre de
problèmes avec eux les infos les
incendies de forêts etc bref j'ai
compris votre problématique je le répète
encore une fois c'est une question qui
relève des compétences régionales mais
je vais en parler avec votre gouverneur
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
pour l'instance
on verra mais j'ai des pays qu avant ce
père qu'il y aurait des résultats
merci pour votre contribution et comment
on dit un jeune arbre je profite de
l'occasion pour vous saluer vous et tous
vos collègues qui travaillent dans des
conditions difficiles sur la lutte
contre les incendies de forêt et donc
ici là la préservation de la santé du
personnel et la santé psychologique
justement concernant le recyclage des
déchets ménagers
il y a beaucoup de messages natalia vous
savez les paroles mais je veux dire que
nous avons reçu environ 2 millions 2000
message est permis ces messages il ya
toutes sortes de questions qui
concernent la réforme de recyclage de
déchets et donc in a traité ces messages
et combien de messages ont été analysés
plusieurs milliers oui tous les messages
qui continuent à arriver
qu'est ce qui préoccupait le citoyen le
plus écouté j'espère que le grand
problème dans le monde sait les justices
des tarifs des vocations de déchets dans
plusieurs régions c'est en fonction de
mètres carrés de logements et non pas le
nombre d'habitants et donc une personne
retraitée qui habite dans un cran au
portement paie plus qu'une famille
nombreuse peu disent qu'il a moins de
déchets est encore un problème c'est
l'absence de l' usine de recyclage de
déchets et il y a donc un grand problème
écologique
monsieur le président c'est sont les
habitants du la commune de silinkine ce
qu'est qui s'adresse à vous voici les
photos et malheureusement il n'y a pas
d'odeur mais vous comprenez que ça va
très mal vie entre dans l'est
républicain de bord et atic il y a
beaucoup de messages des vétérans des
anciens combattants il nous supplient de
protéger leur village c'est une
catastrophe écologique
il y a aussi deux messages des
handicapés qui ne peuvent pas évacuer
leurs déchets mais il paye toujours dans
la région de tver le village de
vassiliev score les habitants peuvent
franchir et 3 km pour évacuer les
déchets parce que ils n'ont pas de
conteneurs 1 pour le déchet est bien sûr
monsieur le président
il y a donc le tri de déchets mais
ensuite que les déchets sont évacués
ensemble mais comment on peut résoudre
ce problème
alors en ce qui concerne donc la réforme
du traitement des déchets c'est un
travail énorme sur l'ensemble du pays et
auparavant comme vous le savez c'est pas
la première fois qu'on en parle
aujourd'hui
mais à l'époque sur l'éthique déjà
pratiquement que personne ne s'est
jamais occupé de cette question est
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale il y
avait évidemment pas autant de déchets
on n'avait pas de société de
consommation enfin maintenant donc en
avons au jour nous avons aujourd'hui 60
millions de tonnes de déchets qui
s'accumulent chaque année nous en sommes
qu'au premier au 1re étape et en ce qui
concerne le tri nous en sommes à dix
millions 2 tonnes et en retraitement il
y en a à peu près 3 millions les années
prochaines nous devons lancer des usines
de d'incinération des déchets et je
comprends qu'un certain nombre de
citoyens qui vivent dans les lieux où
doivent être construites ces usines
manifestent leurs préoccupations mais
encore une fois je veux attirer sur
votre attention sur le fait que dans
aucun pays dans le monde et on ne peut
se passer de ce type de service il faut
bien détruire les déchets est le seul
moyen actuel c'est l'incinération
donc on a des médecins qui travaillent
dans ces zones dites rouges
donc ils sont quasiment obligés de
travailler dans des sortes de
scaphandres ceux qui travaillent sur
dans ses usines c'est à dire que en
dehors du tri des déchets et de
retraitement
nous passons à la halle étape concrète
du retraitement de ces déchets le
gouvernement examine actuellement
l'éventualité d'étendre cette réforme
c'est un travail de vaste ampleur
il y a beaucoup de composantes dans
cette question certains producteurs
d'emballages par exemple des
spécialistes disent que en gros 50 % des
déchets c'est ce sont des emballages le
papier carton sous les formes des femmes
donc ils ont pris eux mêmes proposé de
provo d'installer
des sites de transformation de
retraitement donc il y aurait aussi la
question d'introduire des taxes pour
leur traitement
donc le gouvernement travaille là-dessus
à trouver un accord sur cette question
encore une fois je le répète c'est un
travail considérable
nous ne relâchons pas nos efforts
il va falloir réagir vite
notamment en ce qui concerne les
décharges publiques que vous venez
d'évoquer nous notons cela et nous
allons essayer de réagir rapidement et
de voir avec les autorités locales
mais il ya encore des points qui sont
absolument inacceptables et c'est ce que
je veux dire ici c'est quand les
citoyens sont évidemment outré de voir
alors que eux mêmes et c'est de
respecter les normes en matière de tri
et qu'après on voit tout ça mélangé dans
un seul camion dans une seule ben
évidemment tout cela suscite le
mécontentement parce que les gens voient
que les services ne sont pas effectuer
correctement par les opérateurs qui sont
impliqués dans ce processus et les cas
que vous avez décrit son sens sans aucun
doute justifiée et donc ici elles des
solutions à trouver et pour parler d'une
façon plus globale
on a une ici une responsabilité générale
qui est importante et qui est aussi
celle des producteurs d'emballages et
les producteurs doivent ici réfléchir à
ce processus de recyclage ou travailler
avec le gouvernement pour trouver des
solutions et aussi des budgets mais en
tout cas il ya ici un contact un retour
à entretenir continuer avec tatiana
merci l'écologie ce n'est pas seulement
la rolls recyclage des ordures mais
aussi leurs propres et l'eau propre
comme ce que c'est un anti leader dans
ce domaine c'est très peu de ceux des
messages que j'ai ici pour sortir dans
la rue avec un enfant il faut d'abord
voir l'état de l'air par la fenêtre
c'est de cela que choc plaignent se
plaint à l'une des résidentes maintenant
nous allons essayer de contacter hommes
ce que je vois que nous avons en appel
en direct s'il vous plaît bonjour vous
êtes en direct avec le président jour
bonjour vladimirovitch je m'appelle
casimir je vous appelle à deux hommes ce
qui est une autre question porte
évidemment sur l'écologie en 2018
parce que a fait partie des douze villes
participantes du projet national
écologie air propre mais le 30
juin juin 2021 jusqu'à cette date nous
n'avons pas vu de changement donc la
qualité de l'air a dû améliorer mais on
continue de souffrir de la soute de
carbo et nous avons une très mauvaise
statistique pour des maladies des
poumons
l'anthologie et ses travaux nous nous
adressons à vous monsieur poutine
aujourd'hui si vous pouvez influencer
les les entreprises qui font semblant de
ne pas voir les deux crêpes
présidentielle et pour que nous
puissions respirer commission vivre dans
un cadre un à gaz on vous demande de
l'aide
un message collectif laissant tomber les
murs et toute votre équipe qui est sont
à côté de vos des enfants que je vois je
veux dire la chose suivante il ya eu la
proposition de transférer le
gouvernement à omsk m
mais ça ne va pas résoudre le problème
je suis considéré que oui et il fait il
faudrait transféré quelques structures
fédérales en sibérie au bien des grandes
sociétés les sièges de ses sociétés qui
évoluent en sibérie mais payent des
impôts en mots ce court mais ça c'est
une autre chose concernant l'écologie la
situation qui persistait depuis des
décennies c'était une situation
objective
non pas ce n'était pas la conséquence du
fonctionnement du gouvernement aux biens
des autorités actuelles il y à des
entreprises qui est fonctionne depuis
des décennies et qui polluent lui
l'industrie pour le deuxième pollueur
c'est le système de services communaux
si on a la faire avec la période de
réchauffement ou univers et qui utilise
le mazout et et le charbon et troisième
pollueur c'est le transport concernant
la ville d'homs que vit et aime
votre ville a fait partie de deux fils
où la situation est très compliquée mais
cet objectif de -20%
c'est l'objectif de 2024 et j'espère que
malgré toutes les difficultés
ça sera le cas et je suis conscient du
fait qu'il est très difficile de vivre
dans ces conditions on ne vous en dit
pas je le comprends très bien mais de
toute façon le travail est en cours 1
mais quels sont les volets de notre
activité et qu'est ce que font les
autorités locales ont mis ce que fait
partie de ces douze villes où l'objectif
de la baisse de 20% de d'émissions
polluantes
mais il ya aussi d'autres mesures
concrètes à ce que je sache tout
récemment j'ai eu ce rapport et je suis
en courant qu'est ce qui se passe dans
ces deux villes à omsk il y a quatre
décharges publiques iguerande il y en a
six oui 6 6 5 qui font partie du
programme
mais selon mes documents il y a quatre
grandes décharges publiques et donc les
autorités locales peuvent adresser la
requête qui devrait concerner ces
décharges de requêtes du gouverneur ont
été approuvés mais malheureusement
il n'y a pas de requête qui concerne les
deux restantes et donc les autorités
locales devraient faire attention
et la deuxième chose à faire vous avez
une grande raffinerie qui appartiennent
à gazprom neft et là il y a une grande
concentration des sédiments et donc il y
à une question à résoudre c'est une
grande société est un grand groupe
pétrolier et il nous promet d'ici 2020 3
de recycler 50% de cette décharge
pourquoi 50% parce que il faut être
attentif pour ne pas créer d'autres
problèmes écologiques mais de toute
façon ce travail continue et enfin un
des pollueurs
c'est le transport public et là aussi il
y à des avancées nous avons pris la
décision
comme quoi le système de transport sera
renouvelée dans les villes avec une
situation écologique dangereuse et la
ville d'homs que fait partie de ces
villes et les autorités de la région de
homs que ont mis au point ce programme
ils ont présenté leurs arguments le
gouvernement l'a approuvé également et
nos allons trouver des moyens pour
renouveler le système de transports
publics dans votre ville pour baisser
les émissions
en fait la situation nous oblige
d'entreprendre des mesures radicales par
exemple actuellement nos transitions
non commençons à utiliser des
technologies nouvelles dans l'industrie
mais ce n'est pas ça il faut augmenter
le nombre de postes et écologique et
malgré tout malgré leur réticence des
industriels qui est dit ce que ça coûte
cher il faut contrôler elle a le niveau
de pollution en permanence et réagir à
tout instant on va y travailler
n'ayez pas de doute je peux vous dire à
toute votre équipe
on va le faire faut noter travail
remarqué que tout le monde porte des
masques vous porter des masques c'est
bien une petite remarque je voudrais que
les structures de contrôle aient plus de
pouvoir parce qu'il ya des entreprises
omsk et qui ne respecte pas les
dispositions d'eurostat triple odeur
nous avons de l'acquis chimiques sur le
territoire thrill on va le voir j'ai
noté tout ça oui il faut augmenter la
responsabilité de ces organes de
contrôle mais également leur capacité de
réagir de façon opérationnelle
on va voir merci beaucoup je vous
remercie
c'est moi qui vous remercie c'est bien
de porter attention à ces problèmes et
j'espère que nous allons travailler
ensemble avec les associations puisque
l'association c'est l'outil de
responsables de responsabilité merci à
homme ce que nous avons eu un incendie
nous une immigration pardon un crime et
des incendies en sibérie et qu'est ce
qui se passe avec le climat pourquoi
2 bien sûr pour les six personnes c'est
un message oui mais on a parlé beaucoup
partout dans le monde
c'est un des problèmes persistants qui
est le grand sujet de discussion le
changement climatique
il faut dire qu'il s'agit du
réchauffement global r on le sait et de
nombreuses personnes disaient que cela
est dû en premier lieu avec les
émissions dans l'atmosphère
l'activité humaine co2 il y à des
milliards de mille milliards de tonnes
dans l'atmosphère pourquoi cette
situation est tragique
le climat évolue mais certains disent
que quand le climat va évoluer dans
certaines régions et va s'approcher de
la ligne rouge et l'humanité va encore
acheter quelque chose faire sa
contribution dans ce cas il y aura des
conséquences imprévisibles est très
dangereuse et on va vivre non pas sur la
terre mais sur l'avenue là il fait 500
degrés je crois c'est ça le risque dont
parlent les écologistes c'est le
scénario très dangereux je ne sais pas
si c'est comme ça au nom mais il faut
travailler pour lutter contre le
changement climatique puisque nous
faisons partie de l'univers nous devons
faire tout ce qui est possible de faire
sur le territoire russe
ce changement climatique se fait même
rapidement par rapport à d'autres
régions du monde
mais à cette latitude on peut parler par
exemple des pays scandinaves
quelles sont les conséquences il ya
certains avantages mais il y a aussi des
inconvénients puisque la partie à de
notre territoire à 70% se trouve dans
les latitudes nord est
il y à là permafrost également je vous
rappelle que c'est de la terre gelée à
la profondeur des dizaines et des
centaines de mètres même des kilomètres
il y à des localités là dessus nous
avons une infrastructure dans la région
de perm permafrost re est donc dans le
cas du dégel qu'il y aura des
conséquences sociales économiques très
graves
on devrait y être prêt la deuxième chose
la désertification des territoires qui
sont des territoires agricoles à on peut
il faut il prendre en compte également
nous assumons notre responsabilité nous
respectons nos engagements dans le cadre
des accords internationaux
elle accorde paris avant c'était
l'accord de kyoto
il y a des engagements de la russie qui
dépassent parfois hélas le volume de la
baisse des émissions même en union
européenne
et je suis certain qu'on va le faire et
cela est lié à l'écologie à cela est lié
à l'emploi des nouvelles technologies la
sécurité écologique et dans ces deux
villes et qui ont été mentionné en
particulier la ville dont ce que et dans
d'autres villes je vais pas été
mentionnée on va travailler en fonction
de la situation sur place
mais il y a aussi des projets concrets
par exemple le gouvernement a mis au
point les projets de réagir dans le cas
des changements climatiques ultérieure
dans les volets sensible et les secteurs
par exemple le btp
le secteur de transport construire
l'autoroute en yakoutie c'est quand même
être spécial alors le gouvernement a mis
au point le système de réaction dans dix
secteurs dits critiques ou bien sensible
et on va réagir de façon dans le cadre
des efforts internationaux
on va élargir nos capacités d'absorption
du co2 là nous avons des écrans des
possibilités ses possibilités seront
améliorés les sapeurs pompiers
pris la parole et eux ils jouent un
grand rôle parce que la capacité
d'absorption de nos forêts de nos océans
dont de nos mères est très grande et
alors dans ce cas le rôle est très grand
c'est très important et on va nous
préparer à une chose inévitable
quant au climat dans les relations
internationales les gens posent des
questions sur nos relations avec nos
voisins les plus proches
je donne la parole à balashikha monsieur
poutine
je viens de terminer la onzième année
balashikha balashikha avant de poser ma
question je voudrais encore une fois
souligner un rôle très important que
joue la fédération de russie et vous
dans le règlement du conflit dans le
haut karabakh et je vous en remercie ma
question suivante la russie peut-elle
garantir la sécurité des résidents du
hockey rabat merci oui en effet car elle
la russie a joué un rôle important dans
le règlement de cette crise grave
personne intéressée à ce que la crise
s'approfondit sni l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie ni surtout les habitants du
haut karabakh
parce que l'autre aspect c'est que si
nous vivons tous en bonne harmonie dans
la paix nous créerons des conditions
favorables à la vie des gens la ville
pas seulement son plan de la sécurité
mais c'est sur le plan de la vie
quotidienne c'est à dire le mode de vie
normale le développement économique
et tout cela est plus important pour les
gens pour la population du karabakh
parce que évidemment quand on vit dans
l'angoissé de la reprise éventuelle d'un
conflit c'est toujours une source de
préoccupations et les dirigeants tant de
larmes annick de l'azerbaïdjan
comprennent cette nécessité
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
problèmes qui se sont accumulés pendant
une longue période de temps et donc il
ya déjà la question de la restauration
des infrastructures normal de
délimitation des frontières
c'est le fonctionnement de la frontière
c'est parce qu'en fait dans le passé il
n'y avait pas de véritable frontière
entre les deux états puisqu'ils avaient
simplement une frontière administrative
locale
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui dans ce
processus
les travaux de ce groupe trilatérale se
poursuivent entre l'arménie et la russie
l'azerbaïdjan pour restaurer des
relations normales dans la région et les
bénéficiaires de ces travaux seront
premier lieu évidemment les habitants la
population du haut karabakh et nous
voulons que les choses s'arrangent
effectivement tous ces problèmes se sont
accumulés pendant des décennies en
septembre il y aura l'élection dans la
demande et à vous êtes exprimé récemment
dans la convention
la russie unie pourquoi ou tuer ou
toujours de soutenir ce parti et comment
évaluez-vous le travail du parlement
alors va commencer par le gouvernement
sortant et après je parlerai du parti au
pouvoir
je considère que le parlement de la 7e
législature a non seulement travailler
de façon satisfaisante mais à travailler
comme il le fallait
conformément c'est à dire que les
attentes ont été satisfaites
les résultats sont satisfaisants
ils sont tout à fait au niveau de ce que
doit faire l'organe supérieur législatif
ce qui signifie que ces derniers temps
les députés ont notamment travaillé dans
ces conditions de pandémie il fallait
poursuivre leur travail malgré toutes
les difficultés et menaces qui pouvait
se poser notamment des menaces pour la
vie y est pour la santé donc il fallait
venir sur place pour participer aux
votes prendre des décisions sur des
questions importantes sur la vie du pays
proposez voter des z pour les pour la
population pour les entreprises pour
différents secteurs de l'économie
ici cela n'avait pas été fait la
situation aurait été bien plus difficile
qu'elle n'est en réalité dont on a passé
le pic le plus difficile plus
confortablement que que ça a été même
dans d'autres pays par exemple et ça
c'est grâce au travail des députés de la
douma et je le tiens soulignait de tous
les groupes parlementaires
or 75 25 % des députés ont été malades
mais ils ont fait leur travail et je
pense que il mérite le respect et des
mots de gratitude
donc c'est pas seulement de ma part mais
c'est aussi de la part des électeurs qui
vont voter en septembre prochain
maintenant en ce qui concerne le parti
au pouvoir notre vie
malheureusement ne consiste pas à
célébrer tout un tas de fait les unes
après les autres et à dispenser de
l'argent à droite à gauche
non
quand on a des réserves il faut pas tout
dépensé parce qu'on ne sait pas quelle
sera la prochaine récolte la prochaine
moisson
donc il faut travailler en esprit de
responsabilité
encore une fois je rappelle que dans les
années 90 un certain nombre de un grand
nombre de décisions ont été prises pour
le public et en fait on comprenait bien
que cette décision ne pouvait pas être
exécutée donc c'était une tromperie pour
les électeurs donc c'était des décisions
qui étaient prises simplement pour se
faire lire et après la faute en revenait
à ceux qui étaient pas capables de
remplir ses décisions donc la russie ne
se comporte de cette façon et s'il y a
des mesures à prendre qui sont pas
forcément populaire mais qui sont
nécessaires pour notre pays
les députés de russie unie prennent ces
décisions parce que c'est pas possible
évidemment de d'ignorer toutes ces
difficultés donc parfois on peut pas
tout expliquer les décisions qui sont
prises mais parfois
les décisions sont nécessaires et ce
travail de du parti russie unie
constitue une base solide et le fond
dames le fondement du fonctionnement de
l'état en russie et c'est la garantie
que l'état va prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent et des puisque j'ai été
l'auteur le co fondateur de ce parti
bien évidemment je le soutiens et d'une
manière ou d'une autre et d'ailleurs
notre conversation d'aujourd'hui on
répand dans votre question je dis que
justement se dire que je soutient le
parti au cours de cette campagne
électorale
merci je vous propose d'aller dans le
centre de traitement des messages
alors les filles ça va ou pas n'est là
on s'ennuie pas ici on a beaucoup de
questions
vous savez une fois que le président est
en direct s'il y a toujours en une
percée dans le nombre des messages
monsieur poutine l'euro 2000 21 continue
et les russes ont beaucoup de questions
là dessus
l'une des questions monsieur poutine
l'équipe russe non papa n'a pas quitté
le groupe dans le championnat du
football récemment le groupe l'équipe de
hockey il n'a pas non plus montré de
bons résultats les résultats devraient
être différent dans un pays comme le
nôtre cette question vient de lipetsk
le sport c'est du sport donc il ya des
triomphes il ya des défaites il ya des
échecs mais
notre équipe nationale de hockey n'a pas
su ce que ceux sélectionnés
c'est la même chose pour l'équipe de
football évidemment on peut pas ne pas
remarquer je veux pas entrer dans les
détails mais on a des spécialistes qui
[Musique]
son spécialiste de tout ça moi je
connais plutôt le le judo de toute façon
je ne me considère pas comme un
spécialiste de ces deux sports
faisons leur confiance mais dans ces cas
il ya rien de particulier il faut
réfléchir à la façon à fléchir à ce qui
a été fait ce qui a été positif
il ya un travail de sélection qui a été
fait qui a été fait il faut réfléchir à
ce qu'il faut changer aujourd'hui
notamment dans la sélection des joueurs
qu'il s'agisse du football ou du hockey
et puis il faut continuer il faut pas se
couvrir la tête de cendres mais
continuer à avancer nous avons un
potentiel qui est très bon pour les uns
c'est l'espoir qu'ils sont un moyen de
se détendre pour les autres c'est plutôt
des voyages à l'étranger et peut-être
certains donneurs spectateurs se
préférer à se trouver
à la mer près de la mer mais les
frontières sont fermées
mais beaucoup de personnes ont découvert
leur pays et leurs propres problèmes
parce que baïkal un cri mais les prix
souvent sont plus élevés alors que la
qualité ne correspond pas aux standards
de l'étranger propose de considérer le
sujet du tourisme intérieur
peut-être enfin atteindre la question
depuis kirwe bonjour aliona bonjour
monsieur poutine jours pourquoi les
stations balnéaires russe coûtent plus
chers qu'à l'étranger à peu près les
trente quarante mille roubles de
différences nous pouvons aller en voyage
où tout est compris avec dans un hôtel 3
étoiles avec la mer et la côte très
propre alors que chez nous on offre que
des petits déjeuners la mer n'est pas si
propre que ça et les options deux
étoiles beaucoup de ceux qui y passent
un certain temps se plaignent après nos
après notre cote de leur mauvais état de
santé
voilà pourquoi les touristes russes
n'ont pas envie de se reposer dans la
région du sud parce qu'ils peuvent
surtout ceux qui ont envoyé j'ai le
projet ils peuvent encore comparer parce
qu'ils voient là différentiel n'ont pas
envie de payer plus qu'est ce que je
peux vous dire à lyon à la question et
superficiel
malheureusement depuis de nombreuses
années peu d'argent a été investi dans
le développement des infrastructures
touristiques les gens préféraient aller
à l'étranger
dès que cette possibilité est apparue et
nous sommes un pays de fortes
exportations touristique et et 30 6
milliards de dollars ont été laissés à
l'étranger en 2019 par les touristes
russes
c'est de l'argent qui n'a pas été
investi ici donc nous avons des
programmes de développement du tourisme
en interne au niveau national
là l'objectif ici c'est de développer
les infrastructures touristiques
donc nous avons mis en place une
structure nationale dans laquelle vont
entrer des projets des programmes
touristiques avec des possibilités de
crédit pour les voyages touristiques
avec la participation de d'entreprise et
donc cette première étape qui doit être
fait qui doit être qui consiste à
développer ce secteur touristique en ce
qui concerne les prix exorbitants
je suis d'accord aqua scellier ça veut
dire qu'un certain nombre de pays ouvre
la frontière mais continue à être fermé
on a beaucoup d'habitants chez nous qui
ont peur d'aller à l'étranger et en fait
ils ont peut-être raison
donc en grèce le un jour c'est telle
règle le lendemain ce sont d'autres
règles
on demande des certificats de
vaccination
demain on va demander un test pcr et
c'était après demain ce sera peut-être
autre chose parce que la commission
européenne leur importe leur impose par
dont certaines règles dont tout cela est
complexe et donc on a une surcharge de
nos infrastructures touristiques à
krasnodar par exemple dans la région de
krasnodar en crimée dès que l'offre ne
répondent plus à la demande
on a donc des ruptures ici économique et
j'espère que nous aurons la possibilité
d'augmenter nos d'étendre nos
possibilités d'offres touristiques
actuellement il ya 65 ans tu piques
projets qui sont proposées en matière
touristique
merci à l'honneur on continue monsieur
poutine maintenant divers personnels
cela ne m'est pas parti frère monsieur
poutine comme vous vous reposez est-ce
que vous chantez dans chanson et si vous
chantez quelle chanson préférée vous
mais on continue de parler des vacances
j'ai pas beaucoup de temps pour les
loisirs
mais comme on dit chez nous ici on se
repose chez nous on boit un coup et si
on boit un coup on commence à chanter je
suis russe c'est pourquoi je suis le
même
je ne suis pas différent par rapport à
nos concitoyens
qu'est-ce que nous chantons des chansons
russes des chansons soviétique très
mélodique avec une contenu riche on va
passer dans le centre du traitement des
messages natalia y rivas oui merci je
pense que les gens qui nous ont envoyé
le message
au sujet suivant aurait chanté une
chanson fameuse sur les routes russes
les photos des routes c'est que ce que
nous avons reçu le plus souvent plus
précisément l'absence des routes si on
considère les photos de la logan et
alexis escales dans la région de
smolensk on ne trouve pas trouvé le pot
et la route ils sont justement couvert
de l'eau c'est la route qui mène à
l'école 39 à taganrog par exemple et là
à nijni comme ce que les résidents aux
mesures et leur faut c'est qu'ils sont
de 25 cm ici ce n'est pas la venise
c'est la niche socialiste qui a des
canaux des vrais canaux même des
rivières
bonjour messieurs routine au nom de la
localité bord envoyée je voudrais
m'adresser à vous pour nous aider à
résoudre ce problème
voici le chemin que nous avons qui mène
dans notre lot qu'elle était l'année
dernière la route via le chemin
ferroviaire a été réparé et donc il ya
eu des problèmes de drainage lalo ne
part pas le niveau de l'eau monte
constamment chaque jour c'est comme ça
que nos voitures avancent à leurs
risques et périls
nous avons plusieurs fois saisi
l'administration de la ville mais sans
reposent jusqu'à présent pour résoudre
ce problème nouveau demandons de nous
accorder de l'aide
natalia si je ne me trompe pas oui c'est
notre bien
oui le problème des autoroutes c'est un
problème et pertinents on en parle
beaucoup et toujours
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire et à des
gens qui sont confrontés à ce problème
et à tous nos concitoyens
puisque on nous écoute dans différentes
régions de la russie
nous avons plusieurs catégories de rod
au taureau de fédérale régionale et le
cas là nous avons environ 60 milles
kilomètres d'autoroutes fédéral tandis
qu'oddo routes régionales et il y en a
plus de 500 mille kilomètres et plus
d'un million de kilomètres de routes
locales concernant les autoroutes
fédéral est la première étape l'état
s'occuper de ces autoroutes ce sont des
grandes artères qui sert à transporter
beaucoup de fret de personnes nous avons
85 % d'autoroute fédéral qui sont remis
en état d'ici à 2024 50% d'autoroute
régionales seront remis en état et
ensuite 85 1% d'autoroute locales seront
remis en état et là il ya différents
moyens qui sont utilisés un cycle
complet aux biens rénovation et dans
votre cas et vous avez besoin de cycle
complet de la rénovation de l'autoroute
par exemple là
rénovation et ensuite le l'entretien de
cette route c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
et c'est bien sûr la faute de ceux qui
ont construit cette autoroute à votre
gré avec votre gouverneur alexandre
rousseau je vais parler et on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire
nous avons des moyens qui ont été
débloqués et au niveau régional
également nous pouvons utiliser
également les moyens au niveau fédéral
mais la question sera résolue
monsieur poutine les questions qui nous
vient sur le site d'une natte alias
karenina de tcheliabinsk sur la france
structures au niveau influencer les
situations avec le transport public dans
notre ville
michel dinh c'qui justement la situation
de transport public parce que le métro
ce conseil de paix a été concédée dans
l'urss
nous ne sommes pas une localité je lis
skull elle ne nous entend pas non ça
c'est un message qu'on a reçues sur le
site
c'est le sujet bien connu
oui on construit le métro depuis
longtemps dans la ville de chez les
bises que depuis l'époque soviétique
c'est pas la seule ville qui est fait
face au problème de cette sorte dans la
ville de construire ce qu'il dit a le
même problème
tcheliabinsk a été visité par le vice
premier ministre russe no line il est
maintenant mais que cela va coûter
c'est à dire le métro et le train b hier
dans le centre ville et ensuite le
travail cela va un côté plus de 40
milliards de roubles nous avons cet
argent non seulement pour la ville de
tcheliabinsk aussi pour d'autres
localités où il y a ces problèmes là et
je répète ce sont les moyens qui seront
débloqués pour le développement de
l'infrastructure
ce sont des grands moyens 500 milliards
de roubles et ses problèmes en
particulier les problèmes de la ville de
tcheliabinsk sont sous contrôle
nous comprenons très bien de quels
moyens nous avons besoin il faut
travailler dans cette ville et dans
d'autres villes qui ont les mêmes
problèmes
je vous propose de passer au sujet de
l'économie vous avez parlé de la
prolongation des crédits hypothécaires à
préférentiel sous une autre forme
ce moyen sera gardée à votre avis est-ce
que les crédits hypothécaires ont
augmenté les prix
par exemple l'année dernière les prix
dans les nouvelles maisons ont augmenté
de 12% dans la région de krasnodar en
mètre carré a augmenté dans le coup a
augmenté de 43% belgorod l'appartement
compter en millions 500 mille maintenant
il coûte 3 millions il ya eu d'autres
raisons qui ont influencé la croissance
des prix mais à votre avis ce crédit
peut déclarer ce que c'est un plan c je
veux dans ce cas très impliqué est ce
que ce serait mieux de renoncer à les
parties l'hypothèque à taux
préférentiels donc lors d'une réunion du
gouvernement j'ai parlé de ce problème
quand nous proposons ces mécanismes à
taux préférentiel et il faut contrôler
la hausse des prix il faut contrôler la
réaction du marché et le secteur du
bâtiment ne doit pas connaître la hausse
des prix mais malheureusement c'est
inévitable puisque cela est dû à l'offre
et à la demande
malgré cela
ce taux préférentiel de 2 25%
malgré la hausse des prix et j'avoue que
c'est la réalité et les causes sont
différentes
la hausse des prix de certains matériels
comme le métal mais de toute façon cette
qui pâtit potec a joué son rôle et le
volume de crédit accordé à augmenter
considérablement plus de 500 millions de
personnes ont bénéficié de cette
hypothèque à taux préférentiel et donc
nous avons décidé de poursuivre ce
projet pas à taux y circulent 5% mais 7
5% jusqu'à l'été 2022 et il y a le
montant qui a à été changée 8 mai
l'hypothèque à taux préférentiel a été
maintenue
nous avons maintenu également le taux
préférentiel et les mesures de soutien
aux familles qui possèdent des enfants
d'abord c'était 2% pour les familles
le taux préférentiel pour les familles
avec des enfants et ensuite tout
récemment nous avons décidé de
d'accorder 6% de taux préférentiels pour
les ans pour les familles qui ont tout
le premier enfant qui était né en 2018
ensuite et je crois que c'est un
préférentiel va être bénéfique pour les
gens pour ce que pour parce que pour
certaines catégories en extrême orient
il y à l'hypothèque à taux préférentiel
de 2% par exemple oui il faut élargir
l'offre sur le marché
il faut contrôler le prix des matériaux
de construction
là nous avons des problèmes qui sont
liés
on manque de la de la main d'oeuvre
puisque durant la pandémie
il ya eu des restrictions qui concerne
l'arrivée des ouvriers en provenance des
dossiers de république et cela a eu un
impact aussi sur la hausse des prix mais
on va continuer à travailler
vladimir poutine qu'est ce qui va se
passer ici on a encore d'une question
sms acquis les soeurs aux électeurs
quand les gens votent ils font leur
choix à n'importe quel niveau local
régional et fédéral
et bien sûr dans ce cas le président le
chef de l'état et ce pour donner aux
gens qui ont fait ce choix je propose de
choisir une question qui est sur le mur
par exemple
le tri des déchets la défense
la lutte contre la criminalité je vois
par exemple on a une vidéo direct en
direct avec moscou bonjour vous êtes en
ligne
alizée bonjour monsieur le président
j'ai une question assez brève
aujourd'hui des criminels propose des
certificats de vaccination ou des contre
indications
comment lutter contre ces c'est
l'escroquerie pure il y à une loi qui
punit ses actes il faut que les forces
de l'ordre soient efficaces le ministre
est au courant le ministre de
l'intérieur j'en ai parlé tout récemment
avec lui oui il travaille là dessus et
le recherchent ces personnes là et je
crois que ces personnes là seront punis
c'est ce sont des actes très dangereux
des crimes graves qui sont liées à haut
risque à la santé des gens c'est
inacceptable et je crois que les forces
de l'ordre devraient avoir tôt leur
arsenal pour prévenir ces crimes là
depuis quelques jours à moscou allait
dans les cafés et le ministère de
l'intérieur est au courant et ils
travaillent là dessus je propose de
revenir la question de la vaccination
mais dans un autre contexte
dans les républiques autonomes de
donetsk et
l'ogc à cette question est oui c'est une
question qui nécessite une attention
particulière je crois que 90 mille doses
du vaccin ont été envoyés à donner ce
qu'est un halo gasquet et on va envoyer
encore ça fait déjà plus de trois heures
que nous travaillons encore plus même si
je vous plaît on va passer à des
questions très brève
est-ce que vous entretenez votre
connaissance des langues étrangères est
ce que vous faites des fautes en
allemand mais je commets des fautes en
allemand bien sûr mais mon gros problème
c'est le manque de lexique c'est comme
un instrument musical il faut il jouer
d'un instrument chaque jour pour le
moment je n'ai pas la possibilité de
parler allemand chaque jour et il ya
peut-être j'oublie parfois des mots et
la même chose encore pire
quel est votre profession vous avez
gardé le meilleur souvenir
il ya eu tamara du jeu va de premier
rang en quatrième c'est une femme
merveilleuse verra gourévitch par
exemple de la 5e à la 8e
on est toujours en contact quelle quelle
période de notre histoire vous intéresse
vous paraît la plus intéressante la
meilleure avons eu des grandes époques
beaucoup de grandes époque dans
l'histoire de notre pays de la russie
avant pierre legrand l'époque de pierre
legrand par exemple qui a mené des
réformes et grandiose qui ont transformé
la russie l'époque de la catherine la
grande par exemple
oh bien l'époque d'alexandre premier
quand la russie est devenue une super
puissance ça c'est un fait évident il ya
d'autres époques également et tout cela
doit être l'objet de nos études et on
devrait s'en souvenir
vénéré ces époques ces personnes aient
être digne de leur exemple monsieur le
prix qu'ils vous repasse vos chemises et
savez là vos chaussettes en carré vaut
là où j'habite il y à une blanchisserie
c'est le football je ne sais pas quel
est le numéro 2 se précise
mais de toute façon il ya des personnes
là qui y travaillent jeu
merci pour cette question parce que j'ai
la possibilité de remercier ces gens-là
et remercier ces personnes
malheureusement on ne se voit
pas souvent mais je suis admiratif de
leur travail puisque ces chemises sont
vraiment très propre oui et puisque j'ai
toujours besoin d'être quand même avoir
une asbl parfait comment vous su
résister à tous les malheurs vous savez
je suis habitué comment je le vis tous
les malheurs c'est inévitable parce que
les personnes qui occupait cette
fonction
partant du fait que c'est une chose
naturelle et là ce qui est très
important il faut être certain d'en le
cap que vous prenez et vous avancez en
suivant ce cap comme une prise glace et
là vous pouvez brancher franchir
n'importe quelle classe et surtout ne
pas faire attention ce qui se passe
autour et justement maintenir ce cap
pour atteindre votre objectif
votre principal résultat dont une
présidentielle du passif c'est vrai que
c'est devant moi vous avez plusieurs
fois ci des l'onglet les deux chaises
quelles oeuvres vous pourriez solar
écoutez c'est la guerre et la paix de
léon tolstoï
c'est le premier concerto de tchaïkovski
et le colloque le conte de fées russe et
encore une fois je m'adresse à cette
oeuvre
je demande tous les collègues et occuper
n'importe quelle fonction
pourquoi parce que dès que chaque
collègue vous croyez que les lois ce que
vous entendez c'est une vérité et vous
êtes plongés dans cet état de louanges
sous l'effet de tout ce qu'on vous dit
vous risquez d'être mangés qu'est ce
qu'il faut pour être heureux d'abord un
au premier chef
d'accord je serais bref mais c'est une
question importante philosophie krivine
je comprends je pense que pour être
heureux il faut sentir votre nécessité à
dans la société et avoir la possibilité
de vous réaliser ou vous travaillerez
après votre retraite
à quoi bon travail et je vais se reposer
et la diète c'est quoi pour le régime à
vie j'ai une règle c'est peut-être un
régime alimentaire ou pas mais il faut
quand même consommer avec modération
à quoi vous aimiez jouer quand vous
étiez petit je veux dire les échecs mais
c'est pas vrai comme tout le monde dans
les quartiers de leningrad les cache
cache
c'était peut-être mon jeu préféré
dernière question quel russie vous
voudriez remettre aux à la prochaine
génération
c'est une question que je voudrais
réponse répondre avec des grands mots
mais ça c'est le cas où je voudrais voir
plus large
ici vous permettez oui oui on a du temps
allez-y je vais commencer par des choses
tristes à savoir je veux dire que à
l'époque malheureusement l'union
soviétique s'est effondrée c'était notre
patrie et le noyau de cet état comme un
âne ou la russie historique
la fédération de russie a perdu près
d'une moitié du potentiel industriel de
son économie environ 5 % du potentiel
économique à 50% des populations et une
grande partie de territoire un
territoire très importante du point de
vue industriel économique et développer
très développé du point de vue des
infrastructures hen à et la russie est
historique a investi dans ces
territoires depuis des décennies des
centenaires qu'est ce qu'il fallait
faire avec ce lien il est insensé de
restaurer l'union soviétique c'est pas
possible
et c'est pas raisonnable par exemple les
processus démocratiques dans
démographique dans certaines républiques
ancienne république soviétique
sinon on serait confronté avec des
problèmes sociaux et certains problèmes
de l'information des états des états
indépendants
mais qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire
en russie comment appréhender cette
situation politique et le développement
internes
malgré ces pertes que j'ai mentionné
tout fait tout de même la russie reste
le plus grand pays dans le monde de par
son territoire
vim nous avons beaucoup de territoires
actif mais c'est très important je parle
de la grande voix du nord et j'en passe
sans aucun doute la russie c'est le
trésor mondial de des matières premières
et il faut utiliser ses ressources
raisonnablement et c'est notre grande
avantage concurrentiel
mais notre grand potentiel d'or c'est
pas ces 100 milliards de de dollars et
d'or notre potentiel d'or ce sont les
gens et je le pense non pas par des
paroles et le compte mais parce que je
suis convaincu que c'est comme ça parce
que notre peuple multinationales le
peuple russe
d'abord c'est une un peuple qui possède
une spiritualité qui possède des racines
historiques culturelles très profonde et
c'est très pop
c'est important aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut considérer
comme une substance économique parce que
le monde actuel est liée aux
technologies nouvelles celles à venir du
monde y compris notre pays
mais cette cet esprit spirituel profond
du peuple russe et d'autres peuples de
la fédération de russie est important
parce que à l'intérieur de nous il y à
une sorte de respect envers la science
et l'éducation et cela est lié avec
notre culture 60% de parents dans notre
pays souhaiteraient que leur enfant
s'occuper dans le secteur occuperait
dans les recherches la science crois que
les salaires ne sont pas grands dans ces
secteurs mais les parents le veulent et
c'est très révélateur et l'avenir de
l'humanité et liées à la génétique la
biologie les technologies de
l'information l'intelligence
artificielle tout ce qui est lié avec
ces secteurs et là nous avons eu un
avantage concurrentiel très
substantielle et si on essaye de
maintenir notre stabilité intérieure
le succès viendra et dans ce cas nous
aurons tous les arguments pour dire que
nous vivons dans un état qui est
attractif pour y vivre et nous aurons
tous les raisons de dire tout et raison
de dire que nous vivons dans un grand
pays et à mon avis c'est très important
ce sentiment intérieur de vivre dans un
grand pays et l'attitude envers la
russie
c
et une garantie de l'avenir de la russie
et de notre réussite dans l'avenir de
mon côté je voudrais remercier nos
écouteurs un aux spectateurs les
participants à notre dialogue
encore une fois je voudrais affirmer
qu'on va faire tout notre possible pour
que chaque demande
chaque requête chaque appel soit objet
de l'attention et je remercie nos amis
animatrice pour notre travail commun je
vous remercie